Hallo Leute, ich bin wieder am Start.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen bei euch.
Fällt mir nur gerade so ein, weil der Krieger bei mir aufgeploppt ist in der Empfehlungsliste gerade vor 10 Sekunden.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen.
Oder wie ging das?
Da gab es schon richtige Cringe-Sachen damals.
Ich sage nur die Commander Krieger-Wauzis, Alter.
Das ist wirklich Dice of Cringe-Time, ey.
Sgt. Silver, danke für den Sub.
Ach ja, ich kann euch übrigens winken kurz.
Moment, da muss ich aber umschalten.
Guck mal hier.
Chatke.
Hä?
Was ist das denn für 3 FPS Webcam, Alter?
1, 2, 3 FPS.
Wobei, jetzt geht's?
Ich habe mittlerweile eine GoPro am Start.
Die wollte ich eigentlich hierfür verwenden.
Aber das Ding per USB anzuschließen ist ja schon wieder der übelste Abfuck, ey.
Handlieg.
Monka.
W.
Es ist etwas zu sehr Sleepge die Musik, würde ich sagen, oder?
Ja.
Auch Sleepge-Musik.
Okay.
Geht.
Hör mal auf.
Also.
Ich habe versucht meine GoPro anzuschließen.
Ich habe jetzt hier oben das iPhone wieder dran, da oben.
Guck mal, ich habe gar nicht mehr so dicke Arme wie früher.
Seht ihr das?
Lul.
Weight Loss Champ hier.
Weight Loss Champ.
7 LQRS, danke für den Sub.
Warum nicht?
Ach, das ist Gaming-Musik.
Das ist schon okay.
Was du nicht abspielen darfst, ist...
Was ist denn so Mainstream gerade?
So Mainstream-Pop-Shit und sowas.
Oder generell.
Generell halt so kommerzielle Musik.
So.
Du kannst auch nicht Metallica abspielen oder sowas.
Was ist das?
Äh, das ist das Schild.
Das da.
Das ist, glaube ich, das Schild von...
Von ein paar Handschuhen?
Ja.
Ich glaube, das ist das Schild von ein paar Handschuhen.
Naja.
Metallica claimt quasi proaktiv.
Bevor du überhaupt die Urheberrechtsverletzung begangen hast,
sind die schon am claimen.
Es gibt...
Nur Apple ist noch schneller im Claim als Metallica.
Ne, ich benutze kein Intune.
Gibt's auch Abmahnungen auf Twitch.
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, Abmahnungen sind relativ selten.
Aber es gibt Copyright-Strikes.
Meiner ist wieder weg.
Apple hat sich's wieder anders überlegt.
Zart und Silber, danke für den Sub, gar nicht gesehen.
Ja, wir müssen nicht großartig...
Großartigen Löt-Champ machen heute.
Also, wir müssen im Endeffekt nur...
Ihr seht ja auch, es ist ganz schön staubig hier geworden.
Ich hab's...
Ich hab lange, lange hier den Kram nicht mehr benutzt.
Hier, das Bastel-Streaming-Setup.
Also, ich hab hier meine GoPro am Start,
aber das hier oben ist noch ein iPhone,
weil ich hab mir vorhin angeguckt,
wie man die GoPro in OBS bringt.
Ist eigentlich relativ simpel.
Software installieren und per USB anstöpseln.
Wobei ich nicht verstehe, warum man unbedingt eine extra...
eine extra Software braucht.
Warum meldet sich die GoPro nicht einfach an per USB,
wie sie sich normal gehört, ne, wie eine Kamera.
Aber da ist mir aufgefallen,
um die GoPro-Wire...
alles irgendwie an den Rechner zu bringen,
da müsste man doch irgendwie zig Zusatzsoftware...
Da hatte ich keinen Bock mit...
Null Bock, mich mit auseinanderzusetzen.
Deswegen hab ich jetzt einfach hier wieder oben das...
das iPhone dran gemacht.
Auch wenn's...
irgendwie...
leicht das Geleck teilweise hat.
Vielleicht liegt das aber auch hier dran.
Sekunde, ich probier mal was.
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, es ist ein bisschen besser.
Aber ich mach eh keine superschnellen Bewegungen.
Ja.
Und ich hab mir gedacht, warte mal, wo ist er denn?
Genau, das nächste...
Das nächste Problem war,
die GoPro hat ja diesen komischen...
diesen komischen Dings hier oben, diesen...
dieses GoPro-Ding halt, ne, dieses GoPro.
Und ich hab keine Halterung, die...
hier oben an den...
an die Halterung passt.
Also ich hab zwar jede Menge solcher GoPro-Halterungen an sich,
aber keine GoPro-Halterung,
die hier an dieses komische Gelenk von dem Ring Light dran passt.
Deswegen hab ich gedacht, bevor ich da jetzt ewig rumbastel,
lass ich's bleiben und mach einfach wieder das iPhone dran, und gut, das...
Ja.
Ja, das iPhone, das Fokus teilweise so... so doof hier.
Guck, seht ihr jetzt so?
Das denkt immer so, oh, ich muss Fokus-Champ machen.
Klingt nach einem Job fürs 3D-Drucken.
Näh.
3D-Drucker kriegst ja keine Metallkugel irgendwie da oben hin.
Ich muss mal gucken, wie ich das gescheit mach.
Das... ich...
Ich glaub, die GoPro, gerade wenn ich die per USB anschließe,
müsste schon noch ein bisschen angenehmer sein, als mit dem iPhone.
Aber für die fünf Minuten, wo wir jetzt gleich was löten...
...draufgeschissen.
Äh...
Der hat aber... der hat aber kein, äh, ZigBee, oder?
Ach, der hat auch ZigBee?
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen dem H2...
...und...
...dem C6?
Was ist denn da der Unterschied?
Der Preis!
Ah...
Der hat kein WiFi, der H2, oder?
Der hat nur ZigBee.
Seht ihr das richtig?
Wart mal...
Cheat!
Also nicht Cheat.
Sondern...
...Sheet.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Ne, Bluetooth hat er dabei.
Also, Bluetooth.
Äh, äh, anscheinend...
Ne, kein WiFi. Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur blöd geschrieben.
Du kannst Bluetooth und ZigBee da...
Okay, der... okay, der H2 hat kein WiFi.
Es ist langsam ziemlich undurchsichtig, die ESP32-Chip-Familie, so was es da alles gibt.
Okay, der hat, äh...
...Thread- und ZigBee-Support.
Bluetooth...
Ja, dann ist ja meiner eigentlich...
...wahrscheinlich einfach ein bisschen teurer und...
...hat noch WiFi dabei.
Vermutlich.
Ja...
Also, früher war das easy, durchzublicken.
Du hattest den ESP2866 und du hattest den ESP32.
Fertig.
Irgendwann bin ich dazu übergegangen, einfach für alles und jeden den ESP32 zu nehmen.
Und fertig war.
Und dann haben die angefangen mit...
...ESP32...
...S123...
...C6...
...H2...
...und was es nicht alles gibt.
Und da... da hab ich... bin ich ausgestiegen.
Das war mir dann echt zu viel.
Es war mal kleine... kleine Löt-Champ-Action, dass wir das hinter uns haben.
Ich hab den...
Guck, wie ich das jetzt gescheit mach, dass ich hier was sehe, weil ich hab... ich hab keinen Vorschau.
Die Vorschau hab ich nur...
...nur hier.
Gucken wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, wie gut das funktioniert.
Also, im Prinzip müssen wir folgendes machen, das ist sehr...
...iiz eigentlich.
Massive, massive iiz.
Und zwar, wir müssen einen Temperatursensor...
...hier dran löten.
Und...
...ist nicht übertreiben, ich will den wieder abkriegen danach.
Ja, das ist jetzt nur mal zum testen.
Witzigerweise, ich hab mir so ein paar Pins gekauft, so Stecke... so Steckpins, die ich jetzt...
...leider auf die Schnelle nicht mehr finde.
Sonst hätte ich die mal...
...mal ausprobieren können. Wo hab ich die denn?
Ne, hier sind keine, ja.
Ah, ich hab... ach doch, guck mal.
Oder?
Ne.
Ich hab immer so ein Set... ich weiß nicht... so ein Steck... Steckerpins... wie heißen diese Dinger denn?
So Pins zum reinstecken gekauft, dass man das nicht festlöten muss.
Aber ich hab keine Ahnung, wo ich die hingeschmissen hab.
Bestell... ja!
Die... die liegen... die liegen garantiert in irgendeiner Ecke und so.
Deswegen, wir machen jetzt einfach mal schnell hier ein paar Pins.
Das ist das dumme... ich... ich seh wieder... ich seh wieder nicht richtig.
Das ist das dumme... ich seh wieder... ich seh wieder nicht richtig.
Was? Ich... aber ich denke... doch.
So... so seh ich... so seh ich eigentlich was ganz gut, glaub ich.
Ja, zumindest...
Oh, bevor wir... ich seh's grade.
Bevor wir anfangen Lötchamp zu machen, ich muss unbedingt die andere Spitze draufmachen, weil die ist so klein.
Die ist... die ist wirklich nur für ganz klein... ganz kleines, feines Zeug.
Ihr seht ja, wie dünn die ist. Ihr kennt mir doch immer was.
Ah, das iPhone kann mal wieder nicht richtig fokussieren.
Guck mal, wie dünn die ist. Also...
Damit hast du kaum richtige so Wärmeübertragung.
Dann nehm ich lieber... nehm ich lieber wieder die normale, die ist so ein bisschen fetter.
Ich bräuchte so ein Zwischending, so zwischen der fetten und der...
Ich hab doch... Moment, ich hab irgendwo auch noch eine.
Aber so in meiner Ordnung, ihr wisst wie das... ihr wisst wie's ist, ja.
Hier hab ich noch eine. Die ist ein bisschen... bisschen größer.
Find wieder nix.
Und in meiner Lötkiste liegt irgendwie ein abgeschnittenes USB-Kabel.
Ich weiß nicht, was das da macht.
Naja.
Wir machen das jetzt mal schnell dran.
Eine Runde Lötschamp und dann machen wir weiter.
Proggas stellst.
Also, mein Plan ist...
Für alle, die das... die das letzte Mal nicht dabei waren oder die das...
in den letzten Streams nicht mitgekriegt haben.
Leon, danke schön für den Sub.
Also, mein Plan ist folgendes.
Ich hab mir ein paar ESP82...
Äh, nicht 82. 32.
82, das gibt's.
Ein paar ESP32 C6 besorgt.
Also hier solche... solche Dinger.
Ich zeig immer mal, wie es aus der Verpackung kommt, weil da ist kaum was drin.
Die haben also diese Boards hier.
Die sind ziemlich gut bestückt an Features und an allem, was man so braucht, um ein ESP32-Projekt umzusetzen, was man an eine Batterie hängen kann.
Die Batterien hab ich übrigens mittlerweile auch gefunden.
Also, ich muss sagen, ich hab...
Ich hab mal vor einer Weile aufgeräumt und hab das alles in so...
Guck, ihr seht's hier.
Ich hab die ganzen Komponenten, die ich hab, in so... in so Förmchen.
Einsortiert.
Was ich nicht gemacht hab, ich hab nix vorne drauf gedruckt oder so.
Aber man kann ja...
Man kann...
Im Schrank kann man ja durchgucken und sieht ja, was drin ist.
Und da hab ich jetzt innerhalb von zwei Minuten tatsächlich die Temperatursensoren gefunden und die Batterie.
Wobei, die Batterie brauchen wir nicht.
Wir schließen das Ding jetzt erstmal per USB an.
Naja, zumindest...
Die Boards haben richtig nice Features.
Und zwar...
Ich pack einfach nochmal eins von denen aus, dass man sieht, was da drin ist.
Also, es hält sich echt in Grenzen.
Kostet, wenn man es in Deutschland beschreibt.
9,95 Euro.
Ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, wenn man das von DF Droid Robot in den, ich glaube, USA oder UK bestellt, ist es wahrscheinlich nochmal ne Ecke billiger.
Aber da muss man dann wahrscheinlich, dass es sich lohnt mit dem Versand, eh, auch mal irgendwie 10 oder so bestellen.
Zumindest das Coole an dem Board ist, dass es sehr stromsparend ist.
Also perfekt für...
Für Batterie-Projekte geeignet.
Warum kein Pico?
Habe ich auch hier, aber der hat, der hat kein ZigBee.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwie möglich ist, dass man ZigBee dran kriegt an den Raspberry Pi.
Keine Ahnung.
Weiß nicht, ob es da irgendwelche Add-On-Module oder so gibt.
Kein, kein Shimmer.
Zumindest der hat alles on Board.
Also, ich zeig mal, was, was da alles dabei ist in der Packung.
Es hält sich wirklich ganz hart in Grenzen.
Im Prinzip gibt es da nur ne Plastik, ne Plastiktüte.
Also, ich zeig mal, was, was da alles dabei ist in der Packung.
Es hält sich wirklich ganz hart in Grenzen.
Im Prinzip gibt es da nur ne Plastik.
Ne Plastiktüte.
Mit dem Board drinne.
Und zwei Pin-Header.
Fertig.
Also, die Verpackung hätte man sich fast sparen können.
Und das alles in irgend so ne recycelbare Papiertüte reinschmeißen.
Und gut.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da irgendwelche Add-On-Module oder so gibt.
Kein, kein Shimmer.
Zumindest der hat alles on Board.
Also, ich zeig mal, was, was da alles dabei ist in der Packung.
Es hält sich wirklich ganz hart in Grenzen.
Im Prinzip gibt es da nur ne Plastik.
Ne Plastiktüte.
Mit dem Board drinne.
Und zwei Pin-Header.
Fertig.
Also, die Verpackung hätte man sich fast sparen können.
Und das alles in irgend so ne recycelbare Papiertüte reinschmeißen.
Und gut.
Aber so ist es.
So siehts aus.
Also, im Prinzip gibt es das Board.
Zwei Pin-Header.
Fertig.
Keine Spirenzchen.
Nix irgendwie Advancedes.
Auch keine...
Was ich ein bisschen...
Was ich ja persönlich immer cool finde, ist...
Gibt es aber wenig Hersteller, die das machen.
Wenn man Color-Coding macht.
Also, wenn man Color-Coding macht.
Also ein bisschen...
Wenn man Color-Coding macht.
.
Da hat man wirklich das Billigstmögliche gewählt, wie man das macht.
Aber das ist kein Ding, die kann man hier einfach abknipsen und dann passen sie.
Aber ich brauche die, ich brauche die eh gerade nicht.
Ich meine, wir könnten auch einen Pinheader dran machen.
Da können wir die Sachen vielleicht einfacher dran schöpseln.
Aber die haben überhaupt keine richtigen Anschlüsse dafür.
Zumindest, was ich ja immer ganz cool finde,
wenn die Hersteller Pinheader mit Color-Coding drauf liefern.
Weil man sieht es hier vielleicht, ich hoffe man erkennt es, wenn ich es nah genug dran halte.
Guckt mal, die Pins, oder vielleicht lege ich das da drauf, dann erkennt man es vielleicht besser.
Erkennt man, dass die Pins unterschiedliche Beschriftungen haben und was da dran steht?
Ja, ich glaube erkennt man.
Ja, da hat man zum Beispiel einen Pin für Ground, einen für 3,3 Volt und sowas in der Richtung.
Und ich finde es immer cool, wenn die Hersteller Pinheader mitliefern,
die zumindest Ground und 3,3 Volt oder auch 5,
je nachdem, was die Boards alles für einen Ausgang haben.
5 haben die ja meistens nur, wenn sie per USB angeschlossen sind.
Wenn es dann hier zumindest mal irgendwie so einen roten und einen schwarzen Pinheader und so gibt.
Das finde ich immer nice.
Naja, ich mache das mal weg.
Was wir da jetzt machen ist, wir schnappen uns so einen dieser Temperatursensoren.
Das sind DS18B20.
Das ist so der Feld, Wald und Wiesen.
Wahnsinn.
Dass du Sport machst.
Ja, ich habe doch auch schon gesagt, guckt mal Leute, meine Arme.
Meine Arme sind gar nicht mehr so fett wie früher.
Max, deine Hände sehen mittlerweile so attraktiv aus, Kappa Pride.
Ja, also ich finde auch, dass meine Finger, wenn sie nicht so dick sind, besser aussehen wie dick.
Zumindest das hier sind DS18B20, das sind so die 0815 Temperatursensoren, die es gibt.
Ihr habt es ja gesehen, so sehen die Dinger aus.
Im Anschluss her, easy as fuck.
Ground.
Meine Kabel sind gelb, rot und schwarz, was auch immer das ist.
Hier, ja, so.
Also im Prinzip muss man den einmal an 3,3 Volt anschließen, an Ground und an einen GPIO, fertig.
Ich habe die Dinger auch schon ausgelesen.
An einem ESP32 mit dem Standard Arduino Zeug drauf.
Mal gucken, wie das...
Wie das mit ESP-IDF funktioniert.
Ich meine, wir haben ja das Arduino-Plugin, wir können auch Arduino-Libraries benutzen.
Den Widerstand, den sparen wir uns mal.
Weil die GPIO-Pins selber, die kann man auf Pull-Up stellen.
Und ich glaube, dann brauchen wir das nicht.
Das ist ja im Prinzip ein Pull-Up, wenn man so will, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Von Dings hier auf VCC.
Ja, das...
Das machen wir jetzt.
Also wir löten das Ding dran und dann machen wir Prog-Ausstellungs und gucken, wie wir den Kram ansprechen können.
Aber vorher, bevor ich wieder mit dieser viel zu kleinen Spitze anfange, tauche ich den Kram erstmal schnell aus.
Wie macht man das?
Ich habe es schon ewig nicht mehr gewechselt.
Ich glaube jetzt...
Es geht nicht raus.
Ah, ich bin doof.
Ich muss das gar nicht raus machen.
Guck mal, da ist unten sowas dran schon.
Und jetzt einfach hier rein, hä?
Und drehen.
Easy.
Okay, das ist einfach.
Ich weiß schon, warum ich mir dieses Teil gekauft habe.
Das ist echt nice.
Also, wenn es interessiert, kein Sellout und nichts.
Muss man ein bisschen das Staubart machen, weil das staubig ist.
Das hier ist eine Airsa.
Ja, da sieht man es.
Icon Nano.
Lötstation.
Und das Nice an dem Ding ist, der Lötkolben...
Also man hat hier noch so eine...
Die zeige ich euch aber nicht, weil die ist staubig as fuck.
So eine Halterung für den Lötkolben.
Also kann man die reinstecken.
Zumindest, was ich an der halt wirklich nice finde,
dass das so ein flexibles...
So ein flexibles Kabel ist.
Am Lötkolben.
Also sprich, du kannst hier auch wirklich ganz komische Kurven machen.
Und das funktioniert immer noch.
Und es ist halt sehr leicht.
Das sind nicht diese riesen Prügel an Lötkolben,
die man direkt an die Steckdose anschließt.
So die es für 12,50 Euro beim Aldi gibt.
Sondern ein bisschen teurer, aber das hat sich echt gelohnt.
Also ich muss sagen, ich habe das jetzt...
Ich habe das Teil bestimmt schon 5 Jahre oder so.
Oder länger.
Und ich habe noch nie so viel gelötet wie damit.
Es macht...
Weil es Bock macht.
Ich will kurz was trinken.
Ach ja, genau.
Was ich noch sagen wollte zu dem Board.
Also man sieht, man hat enorm viele GPIO-Anschlüsse.
Plus man hat ein paar Crown-Pins und ein paar 3,3 Volt-Pins.
Aber was halt richtig cool ist.
Das erste ist USB-C.
Also man sieht, dass das in der ESP32 etwas neuere Bauart ist.
USB-C.
Dann hast du hier neben die üblichen Knöpfe für...
Also hier, wenn das iPhone das auf die Reihe kriegt.
Einen Reset-Knopf und einen Boot-Knopf.
Der Boot-Knopf ist dafür,
wenn man mal auf...
Aus Versehen irgendeine Firmware drauf flasht, die kaputt ist.
Die beispielsweise sich immer neu startet.
Oder falsche GPIOs konfiguriert hat.
Und was auch immer.
Und man kommt nicht mehr per Konsole hier USB dran.
Weil man irgendwas so verkackt hat, dass das nicht mehr funktioniert.
Dann kann man den Boot-Knopf gedrückt halten und Reset drücken.
Und dann bootet das in so einem temporären Bootloader-Modus.
Wo man nichts anderes machen kann als flashen.
Deswegen ist es nice, dass das Board die zwei Knöpfe hat.
Dann hat man hier, glaube ich...
Habt ihr eine Ahnung, was das hier ist?
Ich glaube, das ist ein Bootloader.
Ich glaube, das ist für ESP32-Kameras, der Anschluss.
Habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht.
Ob irgendjemand von euch mal ESP32-Cam gemacht hat oder so.
Ich nie.
Ich glaube, das ist der Kameraanschluss hier oben.
Ah ja, Leute.
Ich habe selbstverständlich natürlich mein Antistatik-Halsband.
Genau.
An.
Mein Antistatik-Halsband.
Kann gar nichts passieren.
Also, es muss ja das Halsband sein.
Weil an den Fingern habe ich es...
Ja, an den Händen habe ich es nicht.
Ne, ich gebe zu, ich habe nichts an.
Aber selbst wenn ich das Board kaputt mache, dann ist es halt kaputt.
Ja.
So.
Und das eigentliche Coole an dem Board ist, du hast Bluetooth dabei, ZigBee dabei, WLAN dabei.
Leider nur 2,4 GHz WLAN.
Kein 5 GHz WLAN.
Obwohl die WiFi 6 unterstützen.
Unterstützen sie kein 5 GHz.
Da hatten wir es heute Morgen von.
Ich weiß nicht, was...
Die China-Chinesen dabei gedacht haben.
Zumindest ziemlich, ziemlich beknackt.
Aber es ist leider so.
Meines Wissens nach hat Espressif keinen Controller am Start, der 5 GHz WLAN unterstützt.
Man kann das natürlich sagen.
Wozu?
Ja, es ist eigentlich egal.
Das Ding hat so geringe Datenraten und sie sind wirklich notwendig.
Naja, ich kann dazu bloß sagen.
Manchmal sind die 2,4 GHz Frequenzen so voll, dass es sicherlich nicht schaden würde.
Wenn das Ding 5 GHz WLAN...
Könnte.
Aber ist halt so.
So, und das eigentlich Neiße, was man hier sieht, ist...
Moment, ich muss noch kurz gucken.
Hier, guckt mal.
Da wo mein Finger ist, erkennt man, was da dran steht.
Glaube nicht.
Kennt man das?
Da steht zumindest dran...
Li-Ion.
Also sprich...
Lithium-Ionen-Akkus.
Kann man da direkt dran.
Dran löten.
Man kann die natürlich auch so an die Pins anschließen.
Aber, wenn man die hier dran anschließt, dann ist eine Ladeelektronik dahinter.
Das heißt, man kann mit diesen...
Achso, hier oben kann man die Dinger übrigens auch...
Man sieht es ja hier, ne?
Hier oben kann man das auch anschließen, wenn man eine Batterie hat mit dem passenden Stecker.
Hi, ist Joey. Danke schön für den Sub.
Ich hole mal kurz eine Batterie.
Lass uns mal kurz ausprobieren, ob der dann...
Ich habe vor einer Weile mal alles in solche Kästchen sortiert.
Das hat sich wirklich gelohnt.
Jetzt finde ich den Kram auch.
So, zumindest das hier ist eine...
Oh, guck mal.
2000mAh-Stunden-Batterie.
Da ist sogar richtig was drin, ne?
Und die kann man jetzt da oben anschließen.
Ich hoffe, das ist der gleiche Stecker.
Ja, ist es.
So, und das coole ist, dadurch, dass es jetzt eine Ladeelektronik drin hat, kann ich den jetzt per USB anschließen.
Und das lädt.
Moment, das probieren wir...
Das probieren wir doch knapp mal aus.
Holen wir mal einen USB.
Moment, hier hinten.
Ihr seht das nicht.
Hier ist jetzt diese Lidl-Steckdose.
Der hat ja noch USB-Anschlüsse.
Probieren wir mal aus, ob das jetzt lädt, wenn ich das hier so dran mache.
Ja.
Guck, dass das Batterie-Charge-Symbol ist auf...
Sieht man das?
Das hier unten ist auf rot.
Da, wo mein Daumen ist.
Das Batterie-Charge-Symbol.
Also sprich, du kannst damit sogar die Batterie aufladen.
Da ist eine Ladeelektronik drin.
Und dementsprechend kannst du auch, falls man ein Projekt plant, mit...
...Solar-Panels, kann man sogar hier den Output dran anschließen und über die Ladeelektronik die Batterie laden.
Also, muss ich echt mal sagen, Hut ab vor Dings hier, DF-Robot.
Die haben sich wirklich Gedanken gemacht bei dem Board.
Was ich damit vorhabe, ich will einen Temperatursensor anschließen, der meine Temperatur im Fischteich misst.
Damit mich Home Assistant alarmieren kann, wenn der droht zuzufrieren.
Und das ist halt mitten im Garten.
Da ist kein Anschluss.
Das heißt, es muss schon so 1-2 Jahre mal an der Batterie überleben.
Ja.
Und...
Das verbringt den größten Teil des Tages im Deep Sleep.
Und wacht alle 3-4 Stunden mal auf.
Schickt den neuesten Status per Zigbee und dann wieder...
Ist gut.
Ja.
Zeigt ja den Akkustand auch an.
Da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Aber...
Ich glaube...
Man kann entweder über die Referenzspannung von irgendeinem Pin, müssen wir mal gucken, was da eingebaut ist,
ungefähr sich ableiten, wie viel Ladestand die Batterie noch hat.
Vielleicht gibt es auch direkt die Möglichkeit, das auszulesen.
Da müssen wir mal schauen.
Erinnert mich mal dran.
Ich schreibe mir das mal auf hier.
Also, über Drehgripp 10 geht es bestimmt.
Also, was...
Was ja bei den alten schon ging, ist...
Was ja bei den alten Boards schon ging, die sowas gar nicht dabei haben, ist...
Du konntest dir ein...
Also, du konntest dir ein Kabel legen von deiner Eingangsspannung auf ein Analog-Digital-Converter-GPIO-Pin.
Und dann konntest du auslesen, wie hoch die Spannung ist.
Und dir daran ungefähr ableiten, wie voll die Batterie ist.
Weil die droppen ja.
Die haben ja, glaube ich, standardmäßig...
Ich glaube, wenn sie voll sind, haben sie irgendwas, glaube ich...
Was haben die Dinger?
4,2 Volt oder so, wenn sie...
Oder 3,9 Volt oder irgendwie sowas.
Genau.
Wenn sie voll sind...
Hier steht 3,7 drauf, aber das schwankt ja.
Wenn die voll sind, haben sie irgendwie so um die 4,2, glaube ich.
Und wenn sie leer sind, so um die 3,1, wenn sie fast leer sind.
Also, man kann sich das ungefähr anhand der Batteriespannung ableiten.
So Pima-Daumen habe ich noch im Hinterkopf, wie voll die Batterie ist.
Ich...
Ich hau in Wasser weg, wie nix.
Ist auch warm gewesen, die letzten Tage.
Zumindest...
Langer Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Ich mach das mal raus.
Wir löten jetzt das Zeug an.
Das war ja eigentlich nur...
Rumprobiere gerade.
Batterie machen wir auch wieder ab.
Machen wir mal weg.
So.
Also.
Drankommt, wie gesagt, ein DS18B20 Temperatursensor.
Das sind die 0850.
Temperatursensoren, die man sich so vorstellen kann.
Die gibt es im 10er Pack für ein Appel und ein Ei.
Können wir mal kurz gucken.
Die Dinger kosten.
Gucken wir mal die teuerste Seite ever für Elektronik-Sachen.
DS8, also Amazon ist der Kram schon echt teuer.
Ja, guck mal.
Hier kriegste 10 Stück.
Oder wie viel sind das?
5 Stück.
60.
Das ist teuer as fuck.
Ich hoffe, das sind wenigstens die mit 5 Meter.
Okay, mit 5 Meter Kabel kann man sich das vielleicht noch gefallen lassen.
Aber die gibt es teilweise noch günstiger.
Ja, das sind die eigentlichen Sensoren.
Wobei ich die wasserdichte Verpackung schon nice finde.
Ja.
Also die kriegt man hinterher geschmissen.
Und wenn man die noch zu größeren Stückzahlen in einem Elektronikladen kauft, kosten die nicht viel.
Das sind so quasi die Standard Temperatursensoren überhaupt.
Die hat jeder schon mal, der irgendwas in der Richtung gebastelt hat, glaube ich, verwendet.
Oder?
Sieht es bei euch aus?
Habt ihr auch schon mal so einen probiert?
Also nicht reingebissen.
Nicht reingebissen, sondern probiert damit was zu bauen.
Weil selbst wenn man da mal einen kaputt macht, ist nicht schlimm.
Kein großer Verlust.
Ja.
So.
Dann.
Dann löten wir das doch mal schnell dran.
Ja.
Lötchamp.
Noch ist er nicht an.
Seiz.
Ja.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal.
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten hier?
Ich würde sagen, als erstes machen wir mal ein bisschen.
Als erstes entwirre ich mal meinen Lötkolben.
Ich würde sagen.
Ich würde sagen, als erstes machen wir hier mal ein bisschen.
Was nehmen wir denn für GPIO Pins?
Also guckt mal.
Hier haben wir Ground und 3,3 Volt oben.
Also würde ich sagen.
Wir müssen uns mal die Standard, die Pinbelegung angucken.
Vorher, bevor wir da was dran löten.
Nicht, dass ich irgendwelche Pins benutze, die standardmäßig schon für was anderes benutzt sind.
Und ich die dann irgendwie umkonfigurieren muss oder so.
PSP 32C6 Pinout.
Eine Tabelle ist mir lieber.
So was geht auch.
Also Tabelle wäre eigentlich ganz nice.
Häh?
Gibt es nicht.
Wo gibt es die denn?
Normalerweise gibt es doch immer fertige Tabellen für.
Datasheet, das hatte man gerade oder?
Gut, gucken wir halt hier.
Also.
Das sieht man nichts.
Open Image in new Tab.
Ja.
Also.
Also, wie sieht es mit... GPIO 10.
GPIO 10
sieht
unbenutzt aus.
Haben wir dann sonst noch GPIO...
Leute,
wir nehmen GPIO 18.
Wir nehmen 18.
Also,
also, der hier,
weil...
Ach ne, Moment, wo sind...
Wo sind meine
Sp...
Dinger?
Der nächste GPIO ist
18. Ja.
Der liegt da eigentlich ganz gut.
Migdial, danke schön
für den Sub.
18.
18 und 19
ist eigentlich wurscht. Aber ich such
eben... Normalerweise haben die doch so schöne
Outputs. Für was?
Ja, das ist die Espressif-Benahmung.
Das plicke ich nicht durch, Alter.
Guck mal, ob die...
Ich battle.
Ob das Board von mir direkt sowas hat.
Ich fire...
Beetle C2, ja?
Ne.
Das da?
Pinout?
Ey, scheiß drauf, ich nehm jetzt
GPIO 18.
Hab jetzt keinen Bock, da eben nicht zu gucken.
Moin, Terrorkeks.
So, dann.
Machen wir das doch mal schnell dran.
Also, mach ich das...
Mach ich das jetzt im Stehen oder im
Sitzen? Weiß nicht genau.
So, machen wir diese komischen Dinger hier.
Unten ab.
Also, was haben wir denn da?
Ich hoffe mal, die Farben von dem Zeug hier
stimmt. Also, das hier.
Ich gucke jetzt mal gar nicht nach.
Den roten machen wir an 3,3 Volt dran.
Den schwarzen machen wir an
Ground dran und den
gelben machen wir
an GPIO 18 dran. Okay.
Und dann wird das
schon funktionieren.
Jetzt machen wir erstmal ein bisschen
Lötzen an die...
Hier. Das ist ein Dester.
Hab ich irgendwie mal hier...
Den...
Ne, ich hab nur den...
Den Kombizangen-Champ.
Ja, okay.
Stand was über.
So, ich mach mal die Lötstation an.
Jetzt muss ich den Lötkolben hier reinstecken.
Okay. Mein... Ein Problem,
was ich hier immer im Stream habe,
wenn wir sowas machen, ist...
Ich... Euch fällt das nicht so auf, aber ich
seh immer nix, weil hier oben ist das
Ring-Light drumherum. Ich kann
also nicht nah dran gehen und von oben drauf gehen.
Aufgucken, was man normalerweise braucht.
Ich sitz... Ich sitz quasi hier
auf der Seite davor und kann nur so schräg...
Also ist ein bisschen kacke alles, ja.
Und weil, wenn ich zu... Wenn ich's zu nah an mir
dran hab, dann...
Ja, ähm...
Dann seht ihr nix. Ja, ihr seht ja jetzt
auch nur ganz knapp was. Ich setz mich
mal hin. Ich hoffe... Ich hoffe, das funzt jetzt
halbwegs. So.
Also, machen wir mal ein bisschen.
Machen wir ein bisschen Lötzen hier an die Dinger
dran.
Sieht man was? Ja, ich glaub schon, ne?
So, haben wir ein bisschen Lötzen an
das Kabel dran gemacht.
Jetzt machen wir noch ein bisschen Lötzen an die
GPIOs dran, sodass es dann
relativ easy aneinander pappt.
Lötze... Ich muss
danach das Fenster aufmachen, ja.
Ehemaliger Kollege auf der Arbeit hat gemeint,
er riecht das gerne. Ich find...
Ich riech das nicht gerne.
Es gibt aber auch schlimmeres.
So, wo machen wir das jetzt dran? Hier. Guck.
An den GPIO kommt
3,3 Volt dran. Man sieht nicht wirklich was.
Ich versuch's mal ein bisschen
besser. Hier kommt
3 Volt dran. Hier direkt
Ground.
Ja, dann... Da seh ich nix.
Ich probier's... Ich probier's mal so.
Ob ich das irgendwie
funzt. Jo.
Abtupfen.
Also, ich hab jetzt erst einmal
an
jeweiligen GPIOs.
Man sieht's hier ja.
Wenn das iPhone hat keinen Bock sich
scharf zu stellen. So ein Klecks
drauf gemacht. Und da können wir jetzt
das Kabel dran machen.
Wie wäre ein Spiegel dann die Kamera anders ausgerichtet?
Tja, man kann das bestimmt
super sophisticated machen.
Das Setup.
Aber ich brauch das so selten.
Also, ich würd sagen,
wir fangen an mit
3,3 Volt.
Weil das ist hier unten außen.
Ich hab hier eigentlich auch so ein Teil,
wo man das reinklemmen kann. Wartet mal.
Das probieren wir aus.
Hatte ich lange keinen Anwendungszweck für.
Moment. Mal gucken, ob das besser
funzt damit.
Mega staubig.
Weil so lang nicht verwendet. Ich mach's mal kurz sauber.
Guck mal, ich hab hier so ein Ding.
Bin ich mal gespannt, ob das taugt.
Guck mal, da kann man.
Sowas hier. Kann man sich drauflegen.
Dann hat man so ein Halterungsteil.
Das ist der richtig High IQ
Move jetzt.
Wenn man das so reindingsen hier guckt,
dann kann man das so.
Das ist ja richtig Bro das Teil.
Weiß gar nicht, warum ich das nicht öfters benutze.
Guck mal hier.
Und da sind noch,
wenn einem das nicht reicht,
sind da sogar noch so extra
extra lange dran.
Wobei das jetzt wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen viel
des Guten ist.
Wobei ich jetzt deutlich besser was sehe,
aber ihr nicht. Ja?
Ihr seht jetzt nix mehr.
Ne, das ist unscharf jetzt.
Wir nehmen das Kleine.
So, ist eigentlich nice.
Jetzt kann man hier richtig gut draufgucken.
Ja.
Excellent.
Jetzt seht hoffentlich ihr was ganz gut.
Und ich auch.
Okay.
So, also was hab ich gesagt.
Fangen wir an.
Fangen an mit
3.
3,3 Volt.
Ja.
Eats.
So, als nächstes.
Ey, das ist richtig angenehm mit dem Teil hier.
Das sollte ich mal öfters verwenden.
Dann Ground.
Ja, dran.
Und jetzt, was hab ich gesagt?
GPIO 18, ne?
Ja, easy.
Das sollte ich immer nehmen, das Teil.
Anstatt es da mit der Hand rumzufuddeln.
Fertig.
Richtig big porge.
So, mal grad nochmal anschauen, ob das auch okay ist.
Ey, das ist richtig gut geworden.
Und vor allem so, dass man es auch wieder abkriegt.
Okay.
Gut.
Dann hätten wir das auch.
Dann können wir jetzt wieder umschalten.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie man diesen Sensor ausliest.
Ich schließe das Board jetzt mal an.
Per USB-C.
Da müsste noch die Firmware vom letzten Mal drauf sein.
Ich löscht es jetzt nochmal, weil ich hab
Offstream das noch ein bisschen hübscher gemacht.
So, dass man es auch halbwegs versteht, was passiert.
Okay, ich erase mal den Flash.
Und dann können wir anfangen.
Flash
Erase
Also, ich zeige euch mal,
wie die Firmware aktuell aussieht.
Ist relativ überschaubar.
Das ist alles 156 Zeilen.
Und es passiert nicht viel.
Also, ich hoffe, ich habe das ordentlich gebaut.
Im Prinzip habe ich das, was wir das letzte Mal im Stream
copy-pasted haben, nochmal so nachgebaut,
dass man halbwegs versteht,
was passiert.
Also, es gibt...
Die Partition müssen wir vielleicht
nochmal ein bisschen ändern.
Also, im Prinzip passiert folgendes.
Wenn der Controller bootet, ist hier der Einstieg.
Dann wird erstmal
Arduino initialized.
Was wir jetzt, bis auf ein paar
Helper-Funktionen, noch gar nicht großartig verwenden.
Dann startet
der Zigbee.
Und dann loopt er hier unendlich.
Dann startet der Zigbee. Wenn der Zigbee startet,
sieht folgendermaßen aus.
Viertelwissen.
Dankeschön für Porgas
27.
27er Raid.
Dankeschön.
Ja, dann jumpt er hier rein. Achso.
Na super, jetzt kann ich es euch gar nicht mehr
zeigen.
Weil ich das
Board schon abhab.
Ich will das jetzt auch nicht USB-mäßig.
Egal.
Wollen wir nachher gucken.
Moin Patrick.
Wir haben grad
Temperatursensor dran gelötet.
Und gucken jetzt, wie man den anspricht.
Also, der steigt hier ein.
Dann startet der Zigbee.
Fragt mich bitte nicht, was dieser ganze Shit hier ist.
Das muss man laut dem Tutorial
so machen, damit Zigbee funktioniert.
So wie ich das verstehe,
setzt man als erstes
den Zigbee
Controller.
Was ist das?
Was ist Zigbee 2,4 Gigahertz
auch?
Man stellt hier irgendwie Spezial-Sachen ein.
Für den Zigbee Controller.
Radio-Mode native. Host-Connection-Mode none.
Whatever das Tutorial
sagt. Das ist so.
Sollte es da irgendwelche Fehler
bei geben, dann
lasse ich den Controller crashen.
Achso, das ist übrigens was, was ich selbst gebaut habe.
Das ist
standardmäßig nicht dabei.
Aber im Prinzip ist das einfach nur checken.
Ob der Return-Wert okay ist.
Und wenn nicht, dann
crashen. Und neu starten.
So.
Dann kann man noch ein bisschen mehr Zigbee-Config
einstellen. Man muss ihm sagen, dass man
ein Device-Typ ED ist.
Ach, End-Device ist das. Wir sind ein
Zigbee End-Device.
Ich habe ein gutes Überwachungssystem für zu Hause.
Nicht wirklich.
Ich habe insgesamt 6 Kameras
bei mir daheim.
Ich würde aber nicht so weit
gehen, die zu empfehlen. Ich habe so eine Kombination
aus
billigen Reolink
Kameras. Oh, schon wieder andere
Postleitzahl-Leak. Okay.
Warte, einfach Amazon.
Also ich habe ein paar billige Reolink
Kameras.
Wobei du da echt aufpassen musst, wenn du welche
kaufst. Dass du die kaufst,
ohne Cloud-Zwang.
Die, die rein lokal funktionieren.
Weil ich glaube, das hier ist die, die nur mit
Cloud-Shit funktioniert. Aber ich habe die, die
ohne Cloud-Shit funktioniert. Kann man hier
WiFi-mäßig RTSP den Stream abgreifen.
Also ich habe ein paar
Reolink-Kameras. Noch ein paar
alte Vice-Cams.
Und eine Raspberry Pi Cam. Also sprich,
ich habe insgesamt
Lass mal überlegen. Ich habe zwei
Ich habe zwei kleine
Vice-
Vice-Cam V1.
Die sind schon Jahre alt.
Diese kleinen Fritz-Dinger hier.
Zwei Stück.
Eine hängt über
dem Katzenklo, dass ich weiß, was man sauber machen muss.
Ist ja...
Eine hängt im Keller.
Zum Auslesen vom Druck der Heizung.
Dann habe ich noch eine
Vice-Cam V2.
Die steht im
Flur. Ne, äh,
Hahn heißen die, gell.
Die steht im Flur.
Die habe ich mir damals gekauft,
weil es die super billig gab im Angebot
und man Custom-Firmware drauf flashen kann.
Ihr kennt mich ja, ich verwende nichts mit China-Firmware
und China-Chinesen-App
und Cloud-Only und sowas.
Die kann man flashen. Da gibt es hier
ein Repo
auf Github.
Das hier, das habe ich auf den Kameras
installiert. Da kriegt man RTSP-Server
drauf, kann RTSP-Stream machen.
Von den Kameras.
Zumindest da habe ich insgesamt drei Stück von.
Zwei Vice-Cam V1, eine Vice-Cam Pan.
Dann habe ich noch eine Raspberry Pi Kamera
und
zwei Reolink Kameras.
Eine für die Terrasse und eine
für den Hof.
Im Prinzip ist bei mir verteilt Eingangstür,
Hof,
Terrasse,
Flur, Katzenklo
und Keller.
Die Raspberry Pi Kamera
ist nice.
Eine blöde Sache an der Raspberry Pi Kamera ist,
ich habe noch kein gescheites Setup
gefunden für Infrarot-LEDs,
dass man ein bisschen hell machen kann.
Aber das brauche ich dafür auch nicht.
Meine Raspberry Pi Kamera,
wisst ihr, also man muss ja sagen,
die Dinger sind wirklich, ey, aber Ring,
nee, Ring kommt mir nicht ins
Haus. Das braucht doch auch irgendwelche komische
Cloud- und App-
Geschichten. Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Also die Raspberry Pi
Kamera, die ist wirklich enorm
widerstandsfähig.
Das hätte ich
selbst nicht gedacht. Ich habe
eine Raspberry Pi Kamera am Raspberry Pi
ähm, nicht Pico.
Wie heißt das andere Ding? Zero.
Also das vollwertige, vollwertige
Linux-Kiste drauf. Zero.
Das ist noch ein Zero 1 WLAN.
Wifi, also
Pi Zero W. Der erste
Pi Zero W ist das. Da ist
die Kamera dran.
Das Ding ist wirklich mega
schwachbrüstig. Das hat kaum was
an Raw Power.
Zumindest habe ich
die in den Schrumpfschlauch gesteckt.
Den Raspberry Pi mit der Kamera.
Schrumpfschlauch gesteckt.
Ein Loch reingemacht in den Schrumpfschlauch.
Dort, wo die Kamera
sitzt.
Festgemacht mit Heißkleber.
Und seitdem
liegt diese Kamera
an meiner
Garage
bei Wind und Wetter
auf dem Garagendach.
Und
geht einfach.
Die ist per USB angeschlossen
innen drin.
Die geht einfach.
Also ich meine, die ist wasserdicht
in diesem Schrumpfschlauch drin.
Aber das Ding ist
seit Jahren
im Freien.
In einem schwarzen Schrumpfschlauch.
Also sprich, das Ding wird im Sommer,
wenn da die Sonne drauf scheint, keine Ahnung
80 Grad heiß oder so.
Im Winter, wenn es richtig kalt ist,
minus 10 Grad, das juckt dir das nicht.
Geht einfach.
Es hat überhaupt keine Probleme.
Es läuft einfach.
Richtig Panzermäßig.
Also das ist wirklich sehr stabil.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es das macht.
Aber es geht einfach. Aha.
Okay, Flash ist erased.
Jetzt können wir die Firma...
Ich war ja gerade dabei zu erzählen,
was das Teil macht.
Man muss setzen, dass man ein ZigBee Endgerät ist.
Ich habe absolut keinen
Plastenschimmer, was das alles ist.
Das habe ich direkt straight aus dem Tutorial.
Dann mache ich
Create ZigBee Sensor.
Da stelle ich die ganzen Infos ein,
dass ich eigentlich einen Temperatursensor
über ZigBee exportieren will.
Das funktioniert dann hiermit.
Man muss dem erstmal sagen,
Mindestwerte des Temperatursensors,
Maximalwerte des Temperatursensors.
Also vielleicht sollte ich
vielleicht Mindestwerte
minus 20 oder so machen,
anstatt 0.
Wobei 0 ist auch okay.
Dann muss ich das Ding halt zumachen.
Also Mindestwert,
Maximaltemperaturwert
wird eingestellt.
Dann auch Kram, der straight aus dem Tutorial kommt.
Ich glaube, man sagt hier an der Stelle,
dass es ein
ZigBee Gerät ist, das ich als
Temperatursensor ausgeben soll.
Wenn ich das soweit richtig verstehe.
Dann muss man dem Sensor noch
eine ID geben.
ID 10 ist btw.
ein Temperatursensor.
Warum? Man weiß es nicht.
Das haben sich die ZigBee Leute ausgedacht.
Also ID 10 gleich Temperatursensor.
Da muss man eben noch irgendwelche Profile sagen.
Sensor Device ID
obviously.
Dann kann man noch einstellen,
wie das Ding heißt,
von welchem Hersteller das ist
und weiterer Kram direkt
aus dem Tutorial.
Sollte das irgendwelche Fehler geben,
und danach muss man noch einstellen,
irgendwie in welchem Intervall
ZigBee
Sachen reportet oder sowas.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das ist auch direkt aus dem Tutorial.
Hier muss man nochmal die Sensor IP einstellen.
Minintervall,
Maxintervall, Delta,
U1600
Keine Ahnung.
Es ist aus dem Tutorial.
So.
Und das war es im Prinzip.
Das war es hier.
Und wenn er dann ZigBee bootet,
dann geht er hier rein.
Das war es übrigens dann auch schon mit der Firmware.
Ja, wenn er ZigBee bootet,
dann geht er hier rein
und ruft das mit verschiedenen Signalen auf.
Je nachdem, in welchem Zustand
er gerade bei ZigBee ist.
Also entweder, wenn er das erste Mal startet,
wenn er rebooted wurde,
oder wenn er versucht im ZigBee Netzwerk zu joinen.
Das können wir auch gleich ausprobieren,
weil ich habe hier eine Home Assistant Installation.
Muss mal kurz den ZigBee
Stick wieder reinstecken.
Ich habe hier eine
Home Assistant Installation.
Ist das der ZigBee Stick?
Ja.
Da ist ZigBee drauf, da können wir auch gleich ausprobieren,
ob das funktioniert.
Also das letzte Mal im Stream hat das funktioniert.
Ohne Probleme nach dem Tutorial.
Ich habe aber ja hier jetzt ein bisschen dran rum gebaut.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung mehr,
ob es noch funktioniert.
Ich würde sagen, wir probieren das jetzt einfach mal aus,
ob das funktioniert, okay?
Okay, also.
Ich habe ja gerade den Flash
den Speicher gelöscht.
Okay, wir flashen diese Firmware jetzt mal
auf den... Moment.
Ich muss meinen...
Ich habe doch mir hier irgendwas kopiert.
Was benutzt du für eine VMS-Aufwand?
Kostet die was?
Das ist vor allem eine Workstation. Ja, die kostet was,
aber die kriegst du bei Keyshops schon sehr günstig.
So, ich flash jetzt mal
die Firmware drauf.
Okay, der startet.
Und...
Äh...
Irgendwas ist hier falsch an meiner Ausgabe,
oder?
Da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Network join failed. Ja, das ist richtig.
Ich habe ja noch gar kein Zigbee Network.
Ich glaube, mein Logging
ist etwas... ist etwas pepega.
Ich glaube, ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht.
Also,
ich glaube, das ist eine reine...
Das ist ein reiner Bug in meiner Darstellung,
ja.
Network join. Was habe ich denn hier komisches
programmiert?
Error? Weiß ich nicht.
Error to name.
Ich hätte jetzt...
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass das funktioniert.
Gut, ähm...
Hast du dein Key aus dem Keyshop mal auf Google gesucht?
Nee, aber wer weiß.
Vielleicht haben die den einfach geklaut, ja.
Also,
hier habe ich irgendwas
ernsthaft verkackt bei dem Output.
Also, Network join failed, ist klar.
Das Ding versucht jetzt erstmal dem Zigbee
Netzwerk beizutreten, was es nicht gibt.
Warum ist denn meine... Warum ist denn mein Output
hier so kaputt? Das muss ich gerade mal nachgucken.
Ich mache mal kurz den Status...
den Statuscode weg und flash nochmal
neu.
Ich glaube, ich habe irgendwas...
Ich glaube, ich habe irgendwas nicht richtig escaped
in meinem Output.
Weil das mit dem Logging habe ich vorhin erst noch
eingebaut. Ja.
Also, der hat ein Problem,
wenn der
den... den Error-Statuscode
rendert.
Wo ist das Problem?
Das Problem liegt irgendwo hier dran.
Das ist halt C++
und keine Ahnung, FNT,
Standard, Forward, Arcs...
Was auch immer.
Ich vermute, ich habe hier irgendwas
verkackt, ja.
nicht richtig escaped.
Könnte ich wetten, Leute. Irgendwas... Irgendwas
ist hier... ist hier falsch escaped drinne.
Irgendwas ist hier verkackt.
Aber ich... ich weiß...
Ich weiß nicht was.
Könnte man das jetzt ordentlich fixen?
Oder mal gucken,
woran es überhaupt liegt.
Wir machen jetzt mal hier...
Ich weiß, was wir machen.
Wir schreiben anstatt hier mal
blub irgendwas und gucken, ob
das an den...
Meine, daran liegt es nicht.
Lickpy Network...
Es ist ja auf jeden Fall vorne
das Problem.
Also es liegt hier irgendwie am Error. Ich mach mal hier Cackle
rein und gucken, ob das passt.
Ob das... ob das wirklich an der
Formatierung der...
des Error-Outputs liegt.
Schauen wir mal.
Äh...
FMT Cack...
Ja, ja, ja, ok.
Achso.
Also da geht es nicht kaputt.
Das muss an der...
Das muss an der Formatierung des
Error-Outputs liegen, wo ich irgendwas
kaputt gemacht habe. Also irgendwo hier dran
wird ein Message vielleicht
nicht richtig gesetzt.
Ist Message irgendwie kaputt?
Aha.
Nee.
Es liegt...
Oh, C++, Alter, Mann.
hier irgendwo dran.
Da ist...
Oh Mann, da ist irgendwo was nicht richtig escaped.
Guck mal, ich hab 100 Pro hier irgendwas
verkehrt reingeschrieben.
Boah, ich hab eigentlich gar keinen Bock,
das jetzt zu ver... Zumindest liegt das...
Liegt das nicht...
Da pointert irgendwas falsch
in C++, ja.
Wir können es testweise
das hier nochmal rausschmeißen
und irgendwas reinschreiben.
Ob das dann immer noch kaputt ist?
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass es ein
Encoding-Problem ist. Ich denke, ich hab...
Ich hab das vorhin... Ich hab da vorhin noch
dran rumgebaut. Das hab ich natürlich
nicht ausprobiert, ob da alles funktioniert. Ich dachte,
das ist so easy, obviously.
Geht das alles dann?
Ey, da hat er keine Probleme.
Also, es liegt auf jeden Fall irgendwie
am formatieren.
Wartet mal, wir testen
jetzt mal was.
Wir sagen hier printf
%s
und hauen hier einfach nur den Output raus,
ohne irgendwas anderes damit zu machen.
Gucken, ob der jetzt auch kaputt ist.
Na, Reboot wird uns da nicht
viel helfen, Leute.
Ey, jetzt kommt gar kein Output?
Ah, nee. Okay.
Das liegt... Hä?
Okay, whatever. Alter.
Es... Ey, ich hab
echt kein... Sag mal, ist
printf irgendwie im Arsch oder so?
Wir machen mal was. Wir machen
esp log
warning. Wir tun einfach
mal so. Und dann %s
Output.
Mal da drüber.
Ob das geht? Oh, was ist
jetzt kaputt? Ach so, tag.
Eigentlich hab ich jetzt gar
keinen Bock, das zu debuggen.
Und?
Und? Äh?
Ja, wo kommt es denn her?
Was ist...
Was ist hier... Was ist hier dran
verkehrt?
String formatted? Vielleicht...
String formatted? Da ist ja nix
drin. Und danach die
Arguments. Leute, ich hab absolut
keinen blassen Schimmer, was da...
Was da ein Problem gerade ist.
Also, für mich sieht's so aus, als greift das auf
irgendwie Speicher zu, wo es nicht zugreifen soll. Aber
warum?
Wir haben keine Argumente hier hinten dran.
Daher
kann's nicht kommen. Das sollte eigentlich nur dieser
Format-String sein. Und sonst...
Sonst nix.
Machen wir mal args weg. Das brauchen wir
an der Stelle ja gar nicht.
Da hält man sich wieder mit dem übelsten Bullshit auf.
Ähm... Und jetzt?
Und jetzt?
Hä? Irgendwas
hat er mit meinem Format-String.
Mag er nicht.
Da sollte eigentlich
sigpi-network-join-failed drinnen stehen.
Aber er schreibt...
Okay.
Was hat der für Probleme mit diesem Format-String,
bitteschön?
Was geht denn da gerade kaputt?
Ich sehe nichts, was überhaupt kaputt
gehen könnte, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist richtig.
Jetzt ist alles gut.
Okay, wenn man da jetzt... Was hatte ich da vorhin drin?
sigpi-network-join-failed. Okay.
sigpi-network-join-failed.
Hab ich da aus Versehen vielleicht
irgendwelche
Sonderzeichen
reinfabriziert,
die ich da gar nicht haben will oder so?
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Was ist das denn?
Und wenn ich da nur network-join-failed reinschreibe?
Was ist denn das jetzt schon wieder,
Mann?
Okay.
Ich hab keine Ahnung,
was da...
Wahrscheinlich ist das eindeutig
skill-issue.
Mach mal underscores anstelle von spaces.
Oh, ich glaube, der ist abgekackt.
Ich muss mal kurz Reset-Knopf drücken.
Ist manchmal.
Ich mein, wo kann denn jetzt hier bitteschön noch
ein großartiges Problem sein?
Soll ich mal hier... Moment.
Darf man hier in Format rein?
Oder muss das hier auch ein C
String sein?
Dass es da nicht mal buggt? Keine Ahnung.
Ich probier einfach sinnlos rum.
Aber man würde eigentlich vermuten,
dass man Format in Format
schachteln darf.
Das geht nicht.
Also es scheint ja eindeutig
hier dran zu liegen.
An dem ersten
Format.
Weil wenn ich das wegmache, ist alles gut.
Blub.
So, also es scheint ja
wirklich da dran zu liegen.
Und nicht an dem Output.
Also geben wir jetzt mal nur Blub aus.
Ach, was ist denn jetzt?
Äh...
Ja, okay.
Können wir eigentlich wegmachen.
Das ist
wieder irgendein C++ Shit.
Wenn man am Ende,
wenn man drauf gekommen ist, dann sagt man
Ach ja, logisch.
Hä, das funktioniert?
Also liegt
es an dem...
Also liegt es an dem Zusammenflügen
von...
Aber was ist daran
jetzt kaputt?
Die erste Ausgabe funktioniert
ja offensichtlich.
Leute.
Ich bin mit meinem
C++ Latein am Ende.
Also der erste
String vollkommen okay.
Den zweiten mag er nicht.
Also der hier ist gut.
Aber sobald
ich Blub und Kackel zusammenfüge,
ist es ein Problem.
Und warum ist das so?
Man weiß es nicht.
Fragt ChatGPT.
Ich bin grad nicht eingeloggt.
Also ich hab ernsthaft
überhaupt keine Ahnung, was dem sein
Problem gerade ist.
Liegt es am C-String?
Ne, kannst du auch weglassen.
Format checkt Format in Format.
Oder auch.
Moment.
Achso, ja gut.
Muss man, dass dieses
dass das
gebrinnt Zeug das checkt.
Liegt es am Compile Flag?
Jetzt weiß ich.
Ich bilde mir auch ein, dass das eigentlich
bis jetzt funktioniert hat. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum
der jetzt auf einmal Schmerzen damit hat.
Eigentlich will ich
das gar nicht machen jetzt.
Join failed.
Okay, ich mach das jetzt
nochmal neu.
Ich mach das jetzt nochmal neu.
Wir haben noch ein Format String.
Wo ich hier F einsetze.
So weit, so gut. Da sollte jetzt
eigentlich noch nichts passieren.
Was?
Achso, ich kann Format String nicht in Format String
einsetzen. Okay, das funktioniert nicht.
Ne, habe ich nicht mehr.
Habe ich nicht mehr.
Hat der
irgendwie Probleme
mit so nested Formats
oder so? Aber dann sollte der
Krempel gar nicht kompilieren.
Ach nee, das ist nicht Standard.
Das ist FMT. Mittlerweile
ist es Standard, aber bei ESP 32
Sachen nicht.
Ich checke es echt da so.
Ich meine, es scheint
nichts Schlimmes zu sein.
Es crasht nicht.
Okay, jetzt mal was anderes.
Jetzt mal ganz blöd.
Hier wird er jetzt meckern, dass
ich eine Expression habe,
die not found.
Okay.
Jetzt ist ja kaum noch
ein Unterschied zu da unten.
Und wenn es jetzt geht, verstehe ich es nicht.
Hä?
Und was ist da jetzt
der große Unterschied?
Ah ja, gut.
Dann nennen wir das Output.
Meistens weg.
Mal gucken, ob es jetzt
broken ist.
Äh, what?
Ah, Moment, der ist...
Äh...
Kannst du mal die reine ASCII-Zeichen aus...
Alter Mann, C++, was ist das
Problem jetzt schon wieder?
Expected Primary Expression. What?
Was? Was willst du von mir?
Ah, guck mal, da ist ein
Semikolon drin.
Okay, ja, das hätte man sehen.
Skillissue, Skillissue.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob jetzt die Ausgabe
funktioniert.
Jetzt die Ausgabe, okay.
Okay, und was genau
ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen dem
und dem, was vorhin nicht ging?
Ah ja, irgendwas mit
Standard, Forward, Arcs und so, aber...
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Soll mir recht sein?
Äh, das bleibt jetzt so.
Das bleibt jetzt so. Solange es funktioniert, ist
okay, ja.
Da fehlt jetzt zwar ein bisschen was, aber für
heute soll's das, soll's das
tun, ja. Weil eigentlich will ich Temperatursensor
auslesen und mich nicht mit irgendwelchen komischen
String-Ausgaben und C++-Shit
beschäftigen. So.
Joining ZigBee Network.
Join failed. Okay. Darf ich
denn jetzt auch, ohne dass
er wieder abkankt, ZigBee Network
Join failed schreiben?
Gut.
Also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es funktioniert.
Wir gehen jetzt mal in Home Assistant
und...
130, okay.
Zeitpunkt 130.
Und melden da mal unser ZigBee-Gerät an.
Wir müssen aber vorher
noch... Ja, der Network-Key
ist falsch. Ja, den kannst du ruhig anzeigen.
Ich brauch den eh net.
Ich will...
Ich will, dass wir neu
anfangen mit ZigBee-Integrations.
Delete. Yes.
So.
ZigBee...
ZigBee... Was ist denn da
der Unterschied? ZigBee Home About? Ja.
Ich mach jetzt mal einen ZigBee-Stick.
Der fragt einen jetzt, ob man wieder von vorne anfangen will
oder nicht. Will ich. Ich will einen neuen Key
generieren und alles.
Zumindest bilde ich mir ein, dass er einen das fragt.
Ja.
Erase Network Settings
and create a new network. Jawoll.
Und danach testen wir mit
ZigBee2MQTT, weil eigentlich bin ich
scharf darauf, dass es damit funktioniert.
Ob die Home Assistant-ZigBee-Sache funktioniert,
ist mir relativ egal.
Home Assistant macht Badge.
Kann mir jemand erklären, warum das so lahm ist?
Erschrecklich.
So.
Äh...
Moment, hat der mein...
Was ist das?
Ah! Das ist die...
Das ist die Lidl-Steckdose.
Oder?
Guck mal, der hat mein Gerät schon direkt gefunden.
Temperature unavailable.
Ja, ich hab ja auch noch nichts gesendet.
Guck mal, der hat mein ZigBee-Gerät gleich schon gefunden hier.
Ne, hat er nicht.
Hä?
Ist das noch das alte vom letzten Mal
auf dem Stick drauf?
Ich bin etwas verwirrt gerade.
Hätte der nicht einfach...
Hätte der das nicht eigentlich vergessen sollen, was da drauf...
Okay. Add device.
Ja.
ZigBee Network Joint. Blablabla. Channel Link.
Irgendwas?
Okay.
Ne, guck, da ist es. Da ist es. Zack.
Ja.
Also das hier scheint mir die Steckdose zu sein.
Ach!
Jetzt weiß ich, warum er das zugeordnet hat.
Weil wir das letzte Mal das schon mit Home Assistant gepairt haben.
Das hat überhaupt nichts mit dem Stick zu tun.
Das sind einfach noch alte Geräte.
Die können wir jetzt hier rausschmeißen im Prinzip.
So. Das ist der alte.
Den... Wie löscht man den Shit jetzt?
Remove.
Und die Lidl Steckdosenleiste.
Ja.
So, passt. Wir haben aktuell
minus 327 Grad. Easy.
Also das Pairen hat funktioniert mit dem Gerät.
Also ihr seht hier, da
hat sich verbunden mit meinem
Home Assistant ZigBee Network.
Jetzt checken wir mal, ob wenn ich reboote,
ob er sich wieder reconnectet.
In den ZigBee.
Joining ZigBee Network.
Ich glaube, der ist gejoined.
Der ist... Ich bin bloß zu...
Keine Ausgabe gemacht. Kann das sein?
Hier fehlt noch eine Ausgabe.
Guck mal, der sagt hier, Status ist okay.
Aber ich glaube hier
haben wir noch eine Ausgabe.
Weil es ist Factory New
ist es nicht. Es hat auch keinen Error.
Hier fehlt einfach noch eine Ausgabe.
Jetzt können wir vielleicht eine extra Funktion auslagern.
Lass mal kurz flashen.
Das ist ein ESP32C6.
In den ZigBee. ZigBee. Ja.
Okay. Funktioniert. Also.
Der ZigBee Part funktioniert.
Ich übertrage noch per ZigBee keinerlei
Daten. Das haben wir das letzte Mal testweise
schon gemacht. Das funktioniert.
Aber ich will jetzt auch nicht wieder
Fake-Daten übertragen, sondern ich will jetzt meinen
Temperatursensor auslesen.
Aber vorher, Leute. Ich muss mal kurz was verbringen.
So.
Da bin ich wieder. Was kann man da sonst noch einblenden
lassen?
RSSI.
Ja, das ist gar nicht so übel. Das können wir tatsächlich
einblenden.
Wie auch immer man das aktiviert.
Das ist nämlich
die Empfangsstärke. Warum eigentlich
ein Weg über ZigBee zu MQTT und nicht
direkt MQTT?
Weil
ZigBee irgendwie in
MQTT reinkommen muss. Außerdem geht's
noch nicht mal über MQTT aktuell.
Es geht über die native
Home Assistant Integration.
Es ist nur ZigBee ohne MQTT.
Was ich mit
Home Assistant steuer?
Boah. Sehr vieles
steuer ich mit Home Assistant.
Ich hab ne Anzeige, was
in meinem Elektroauto
abgeht.
Die Wetterstation.
Wann der Müll rausgebracht werden muss.
Der Wasserdruck in der Heizung.
Generell die Heizung.
Dann ob es irgendwo Überschwemmungen
im Keller gibt.
Licht teilweise.
Im Wohnzimmer
das Shield TV. Die Heizungsthermostate.
Mehrere
Steckdosen, LED
Leisten.
Den Heizlüfter im Bad.
Ganz wichtig.
Steuern kann ich da drüber.
Ich klicke hier grad mal durch.
Weil so viel Zeug ist, dass ich mir die Hälfte nicht merken kann.
Sogar mein Weihnachtsbaum.
Steckdose im Stall.
Und das wird
jetzt für den Fischteich.
Fischteich.
Aha. RSSI is unknown.
Sadge.
Dann wird's wieder disabled.
Ok. Also. ZigBee
Kunst.
Jetzt müssen wir schauen, wie wir den Temperatursensor
auslesen. Also.
DEDF.
Gucken wir mal, ob es da schon fertige Libraries oder sowas für gibt.
Example
Driver. Aha.
Ok.
ESP32 kompatibel
Example for integrated
Ok.
ESP
OWB.
Es gibt doch bestimmt
irgendwelche offiziellen Libraries
für so ein verbreitetes Ding.
Ok.
Ich hab ne Idee. Wir suchen mal in der ESP
Registry.
Warum hast du einen Heizlüfter im Bad?
Weil's mir manchmal
zu kalt ist und ich schnell warm
haben will.
DS18
DS.
Doch, doch. Da ist
ne Heizung drin.
ESP kann doch per WLAN MQTT.
Ja, aber nicht aus dem Garten raus.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich's über
ZigBee machen will. Das kommt in
Fischteich im Garten. Das muss erstens
mit Batterie laufen. WLAN und Batterie
verträgt sich meistens nicht so gut.
Und es braucht
ne größere Reichweite.
Ich hab im Garten kein WLAN Empfang.
Aber ich hab ein paar
ZigBee Steckdosen in den Stellen.
Das heißt, da wird das Signal
weitergeleitet.
ZigBee ist da wie gemacht für. Was haben wir denn
hier? DS18B20
Device Driver.
Das sieht doch gut aus. Das will ich haben.
Add
Dependency DS18B20
...
Du hast Stelle, wann wo Bauernhof.
Da war früher, also
meine Uroma oder so, die haben
da noch Viecher drinne gehabt.
Mittlerweile sind die
leer. Das sind drei Stelle sind das.
In dem einen ist
die olle Werkstatt vom
Opa drin, in die ich nicht reingehe,
weil das alles so dreckig ist.
Und die anderen sind mittlerweile
nur Abstellkram.
ZigBee ist Mesh, ja.
ZigBee ist mehr Mesh als WLAN
Mesh. Kannst du ein Kabel
gebundenes System aufbauen. Wie soll ich
ein Kabel in den Garten zu meinem Fischteich
legen, ohne in einem halben Hof aufzubuddeln?
Telefonmast.
Schnurrtelefon bauen.
Leute, wir machen
Laser
Kommunikation am besten.
ZigBee ist da wie
gemacht für.
Also, wie funsten das jetzt?
Vielleicht sollen wir erst mal bilden.
Einmal Buildchamp.
Ja. Compiler stellts.
Wie sieht's aus?
Erst mal das halbe Internet kompilieren.
Ich mach einfach, Leute,
ich mach ne LTE-Karte rein.
Warum kompliziert, wenn's auch einfach
geht?
Also, wie funst das jetzt hier?
One Wire Bus?
Kein Dark Fiber.
Du weißt, warum es Dark Fiber heißt,
ne?
Weil die Dinger schon liegen und unbenutzt sind.
Ich versuch da hier gerade halbwegs
durchzublicken, wie das funst.
Also, ich
lass uns mal wieder
copy-pasten.
Wir machen mal hier sowas.
Void
Init Sensor.
So.
Und da kommt jetzt rein.
One Bus Handle.
GPIO.
Okay, wir machen
was hab ich gesagt? GPIO 18
haben wir dran gelötet, gell?
GPIO Nummer
18.
Das ist nicht included?
Okay, ja.
Dann includen wir das mal.
Include.
Wie heißt denn der Kram?
Die eigentliche Library? DS irgendwas?
DS? Sowas hier?
Reicht das zum
includen? Ja.
Also, Bus gleich 0.
Bus Config.
One Wire Bus. Okay.
Ich kopier das mal.
Ich weiß eh nicht, was das macht.
Ist undefined.
Warum ist das jetzt undefined?
Muss ich auch noch
include
one wire
bus vielleicht?
Ja, nice.
So, dann
Error checken.
Moment, die haben mehrere Devices.
Ich copy-paste mir mal das gesamte
Ding und dann räum ich das gerade mal ein bisschen auf.
Zum testen können wir uns
diesen ganzen Schmodder hier übrigens sparen.
Wir schmeißen das
Delay raus und wir schmeißen die ganze
Zigbee Geschichte raus. Wir wollen ja
eigentlich nur
Init Sensor.
Wir wollen ja eigentlich nur mal gucken, ob
der Sensor funktioniert.
Init Sensor.
Warum Handle? Nein.
Wir haben einen. Das reicht.
Wer braucht
Kommentare, wenn man das einfach
first try richtig macht?
Error check. Log.
Creating. Starting.
Search.
Alles klar.
Logs kommen weg.
So, die Schleife brauchen
wir jetzt auch nicht
mehr, weil wir nur noch
einen haben.
Search
Result. ESP okay. Ja, das ist
in Ordnung. Das ist auch
gut. New Device.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Wir brauchen im Prinzip nur noch das Handle
dafür.
So.
Logger.
Log
Info.
Found.
Unknown.
So, da sieht es doch schon ein bisschen
simpler aus. Error check.
Okay.
Logger.
Pogu.
Okay, wenn Pogu im Chat
äh, im Chat
in der
Konsole steht, dann wissen wir, dass er
irgendwas gefunden hat.
Okay, wir haben das schon mal ohne Compile-Fehler
hinbekommen. Das ist enorm, Pog.
Weil das ist C++.
Pogu!
Er hat den
Temperatursensor gefunden.
Schließe ich da draus zumindest.
Er sagt Found
und Pogu. Was natürlich
obviously jedem sagen sollte und der
Temperatursensor wurde entdeckt.
Also, wenn das nicht die aussagekräftigste
Log-Meldung
aller Zeiten ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
So, wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Triggering a temperature
conversion and then
reading the data.
Okay.
Dann readen wir mal
die Data.
Also, das hier brauchen wir schon wieder alles nicht.
Äh, das
gibt es auch nur einmal.
Das gibt es weiterhin auch nur einmal.
Äh, Temperature haben wir nicht
angelegt. Was muss denn das für ein Typ sein?
Ein Float.
Float temp.
Ich mag Abkürzungen.
So.
Und dann Logger
Log
Info
Äh, ja.
Temp.
Ach ja. Und vorher müssen
wir das Ganze. Ich habe doch irgendwie so eine
Convert Function. Convert
Sensor. Ja, also
Zigbee kann mit Floats nichts anfangen.
Deswegen
muss man das Float
mal 100 nehmen
und dann als in 16
casten. Ist das
jetzt Temperature oder Temporary?
Ja, das ist Interpretationssache.
Das ist um das Skill Level
des Entwicklers zu raisen. Bisschen.
Du willst die Temperatur aus deinem Fischteich loggen.
Korrekt.
Also wir sollten hier irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 20 Grad
oder so drin haben.
22,8
Es funzt.
Okay, Leute. Ich setz mich jetzt mal
drauf.
Ich setz mich jetzt mal drauf. Jetzt sollte es gleich wärmer
werden, okay? Achso, wir sollten das vielleicht noch
in der Schleife packen, dass der
Wir packen das noch mal kurz in der Schleife.
While. True.
True 0 W.
Delay.
Jede Sekunde, okay?
War mal die Ausgabe.
Zeigst du das auf Onlyfans?
Nur Fansly.
Onlyfans ist out.
Ich bin auf Fansly.
Okay, 2. Aha, also
Moment. Ich setz mich mal kurz drauf.
Also nur drauf
setzen. Jetzt kein
Kein Zäpfchen oder so,
ja?
Okay, ich setze drauf.
Es geht hoch, Leute.
23,3
23,6
23,8
Guck mal, er checkt, dass ich drauf
setze. Die Frage
ist, jetzt lassen die Leute
alle wieder ihre Fantasien im Chat aus, Alter.
Lass mal einen fahren, Mann.
Und jetzt, wenn ich das wieder raus,
also,
ich aufpassen,
nicht, wenn ich es einfach hier wieder
raushole, ja, nicht rausziehe,
nicht, dass man jetzt das Falsche denkt,
ähm,
dann mal gucken, ob es wieder,
ob es wieder kälter wird.
Klemm mal unter Arm und guckt,
ob es auf 36 Grad kommt. Gute Idee.
Die Frage ist noch, wie genau das Ding ist.
Die Dinger sind recht, recht gut.
Sie wird damit jetzt
nichts Wissenschaftliches durchführen
oder so. Okay, wir sind jetzt
bei 3, es steigt immer noch weiter.
Leute, ich muss hier
nebenbei mal was futtern, ja.
Sonst ist es nämlich
durchgeweicht.
Das ist übelst gesundes Zeug,
was ich hier zum Essen hab.
Das hätte ich selbst vor ein paar Jahren noch nicht gedacht, dass ich sowas
esse. Das ist
Haferflocken.
Quark mit Haferflocken
und, äh, wie heißt
das? Blaubeeren.
Sonst weicht das nämlich zu sehr durch.
Oh, ne, Leute.
Ich steck's mir mal
unter den Arm
und wir gucken,
so Fieberthermometer
mäßig,
ob das irgendwie 36 Grad wird gleich.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich drauf sitze,
ist,
ist wahrscheinlich, jetzt kann ich meinen linken Arm
nicht bewegen, weil ich das da drunter stecken hab.
Das ist ziemlich
suboptimal zum Essen.
Also das sollte jetzt bei,
also maximal 37 Grad halt aufhören.
Ähm,
ja, ich hab was
zu XZ gesagt, aber das ist schon ein paar Tage her.
Seitdem nicht mehr.
Nix, was man sich im Wort angucken müsste.
Sieht auch gut aus, oder?
Es wird eindeutig langsamer.
Mehr,
mehr macht's grade nicht.
Es nähert sich dem an.
Ich setz mich
nochmal drauf. Gucken, ob es da wärmer wird.
Ne.
Es wird kälter. Mein, äh,
liegt.
Mein Arsch ist kälter, als mein Arm.
Mit Hose oder ohne.
Mit.
Aber man sieht,
die Temperatur kommt auf jeden Fall
schon ungefähr hin.
Okay. Ich schmeiß das mal wieder auf
die Erde, mal gucken. Dann müssten wir wieder
gleich so 22 Grad oder sowas haben.
22,87
Also man sieht,
der schnellste Sensor ist das
jetzt nicht.
Das Material muss sich ja auch erstmal
anpassen wieder und sowas.
Aber man sieht, die sind schon recht genau.
Dauerhafte Arschtemperatureinblendung.
Warum sollte das irgendjemand,
der zuschaut im Stream, interessieren,
was mein Poppes für eine Temperatur hat?
Wie weit geht der Sensor bis ins
Minus? Kann ich dir sagen.
Der kann
minus 55 bis
125 Grad.
Also nix zum in Backofen hängen.
0,5 Grad
plus minus 0,5 Grad.
Genauigkeit zwischen
minus 10 und plus 85.
Also die Dinger sind einfach billig
und genau genug.
Und wasserdicht vor allem.
Was ist denn bitteschön der
Parasitic Power Mode?
Holt er sich da seine Spannung aus dem
GPIO Pin oder wie?
Sehe ich das richtig? Du musst gar kein VCC
anschließen. So ist aber auf jeden Fall
die schönere Variante.
Ich habe ja auch genug Pins.
Guck, das geht wieder runter.
Also das kommt schon gut hin.
Wir brauchen
1,5
Mikroampere zum Abfragen.
Das ist kein Ding.
Weil der fragt ja nur alle 4 Stunden ab.
Also Leute, ich muss mal kurz fertig essen.
Sonst
weicht das hier zu sehr durch.
2 Drittel sind schon weg.
Aber findet ihr nicht auch,
dass es erstaunlich easy
war, das jetzt auszulesen?
Ich mein, das hier ist alles, was man braucht.
Ok.
Komplexität steckt in der Library drin.
Aber whatever.
Interessiert mich ja nicht.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, was das Ding hier so genau treibt,
aber ich mein,
warum auch?
Schau mal, wir können das doch ein bisschen schöner machen.
Wir haben eine ordentliche Log-Meldung.
Wie sagst du dem nun, dass er in Deep Sleep gehen soll,
nach 4 wieder?
Ja, das müsstest du hier unten machen. Da würdest du sagen,
boah, hab ich schon lange nicht mehr gemacht Deep Sleep.
Also hier machst du Deep Sleep Start
und dann kannst du ihm vorher sagen,
wann er wieder aufwachen soll.
Und dann sagst du Deep Sleep.
Und dann sleept er.
Und dann wacht er auf
und macht genau den gleichen Schritt wieder
und geht wieder in Deep Sleep.
Klingt sehr traurig.
Meint ihr, der ist sad, gell?
Der ESP32?
Das wäre aber traurig,
wenn der sad ist.
Ich will nicht,
dass mein Microcontroller sad ist.
Also,
Microcontroller sad ist.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Wir gehen das mal ein bisschen um.
Next Device.
Machen wir auch dahin. Ich habe eine Idee.
Wenn wir das ein bisschen vereinfachen können.
Ich nenne den Kram auch mal um.
Next Device.
Ich mag die Schreibweise einfach besser.
Busconfig.
So, und jetzt
machen wir
das brauchen wir schon mal gar nicht mehr.
Das machen wir jetzt global.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Muss man das Static machen?
Static
Sensor Handle
So, okay.
Ich habe eine Idee, was wir machen können.
Ich habe mir nämlich was gebaut für ESP
Fehler Codes. Und zwar, pass mal auf.
Fifat Mode kommt jetzt.
Exzellenter Fifat Mode.
Guck mal, ich habe mich ein bisschen von
der C Sharp Standard Library
inspirieren lassen. Ich habe hier eine Methode
gebaut. ESP Error
Any. Und dem kann man
Errors übergeben.
Und beim ersten
Error,
der wirklich eine Fehlermeldung ist,
geht er raus.
Und returned true.
Also könnte ich jetzt ja sagen.
Also quasi sowas hier.
Nur schöner.
Also könnte ich quasi sagen.
ESP Error. Any.
Dann haue ich den
hier rein.
Das machen wir weg.
Dann haue ich den hier rein.
Next device.
Und da machen wir jetzt
ein If drum herum.
Und wenn das
Ah, man kann es nicht.
Das ist hässlich, oder?
Leute, wir nutzen
C++ Magic.
Können wir das nicht
converten automatisch in einen Bool?
Ähm.
Wie geht denn das?
C++ Implicit
Convert Bool.
Wie macht man sowas denn?
Oh, ich muss immer noch fertig essen.
So, hä?
Äh.
What? Wolltest du es jetzt?
Das geht. Guck mal. Ey, das ist ja richtig
Pfeifert.
Jetzt kann ich da sogar ein If schreiben.
Das ist doch schöne Schreibweise hier.
Any ESP Error. Dann.
Log.
Log Error.
No Sensor Found.
Und dann Reboot, weil dann kann ich eh nicht weitermachen.
Ich finde das ist richtig gut lesbar, oder?
Besser als fünfmal gerappt.
Äh. Check Error.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Äh. Config.
Wir können das sogar noch weiter treiben.
Wir können das hier nehmen.
Config. Schreiben wir das mal aus.
Config.
Semikolon.
Wir können sogar das hier noch reinpacken.
Text. Device.
ES. Config.
Sensor. Handle.
Und jetzt können wir uns diesen ganzen
Shit
hier sparen.
Ich glaube, ich habe ein bisschen zu viel gelöscht.
Ich bin mir nicht
so ganz sicher gerade.
Noch besser?
Wir können das noch pfeilfertiger machen.
Ja.
Wir können meistens scheiß auf Bool
Overload.
Wir können einfach sagen.
Weil wir wollen ja eh abbrechen, Leute.
Wir wollen ja eh abbrechen. Guck mal. Wir können einfach sagen.
Logger.
Abbruch, wenn Error.
Das hier rein.
Plus die Default Fehlermeldung.
Easy.
Ey, das gefällt mir jetzt.
Das ist auch finde ich ganz gut lesbar, ja.
Abkacken, wenn es irgendeinen Fehler
hierbei gibt. Mit dieser Meldung.
So, das hier. Ja, das können wir
lassen. Wobei, da können wir das auch benutzen.
Hier. Mein selbst gebastelter
Overload.
Logu. Logpogu.
Sensor. Handle. Wir schauen mal, ob das jetzt
noch funktioniert nach meiner
Bastelei hier. Chat, was meint ihr?
Funktioniert das noch oder wird es nicht funktionieren?
Habe ich irgendwo einen Denkfehler drin? Okay, wir
bilden erst mal.
Also, wir haben wieder 23,
23,12,
23,18 Grad.
Geht. First try.
Ich muss sagen.
Das ist echt
halbwegs
lesbar.
Wir können noch sagen, hier unten.
Logger.
Loginfo.
Es gibt nämlich,
ähm.
Wo war das?
Man konnte irgendwie, ich glaube Next Device
oder so. Next Device.
Address, genau.
Sagen wir jetzt hier.
Prozent. Ne, nicht
Prozent X.
X. Glaube so.
Hier. Found
Sensor.
Found Sensor. Add.
Ne, es ist Doppelpunkt X.
Doppelpunkt X.
Sollte er sogar ausgeben,
dass er einen Sensor gefunden hat und dass er jetzt
anfängt Sachen auszulesen.
Oder auch die Adresse vom Sensor.
Mal gucken, was er von der Adresse überhaupt ausgibt.
Hier. Found Sensor. Add.
Natürlich. An der Adresse. Ja. Logger.
Hätte ich vorher gewusst.
Hätten wir eigentlich gar nicht ausgeben müssen.
Aber es funktioniert.
Übrigens, ich finde meine Logausgabe
viel schöner in der Formatierung.
Auch mit dem fetten Info und sowas.
Als die offizielle ESP Logausgabe.
Guck mal. Ihr seht ja.
Ich habe sogar in meinem Logoutput
zu Debugzwecken
die Datei und die Zeile
wo der Logoutput geschrieben wird.
Also sprich, wenn da jetzt als
Output kommt Error. Könnte ich sogar
nachgucken.
Welche Zeile das ist.
Ja, das war es.
Nicht für heute, aber für das
Auslesen vom Sensor.
Jetzt müssen wir den Kram hier
bloß noch
verpacken
in einen eigenen Thread
oder in eine eigene Schleife.
Die wir dann
per Zigbee
an Home Assistant schicken.
Also.
Starten wir Zigbee.
Nach Init Sensor
kriegt er mal 500
Millisekunden Zeit.
Wobei, das Ding läuft später an der Batterie.
Er kriegt 100 Millisekunden Zeit
sich zu akklimatisieren.
Die neue Home Assistant
Updates.
Ja, ich lese immer den Blog.
So, jetzt starten wir noch einen neuen Tag.
Ach übrigens, wisst ihr was mein Logger auch macht?
Mein Logger ist richtig pfeifett.
Der loggt die
Namen vom Task mit.
So, jetzt machen wir
sowas wie Zigbee.
Nennen wir das ganze mal Sensor.
Start Start
Start Sensor ist doof.
Start Read Sensor
vielleicht sowas.
Start
Read Sensor
Ok, und der soll jetzt im Hintergrund
Temperatur auslesen und per
Zigbee schicken.
Also, nachdem es ja ein eigener
Task ist, while true.
Und da kommt
ein Delay von einer Sekunde
rein.
Oder komm, von 5 Sekunden.
Jetzt zum ausprobieren.
Oder interessiert dich was
Konkretes, was ich irgendwie zu irgendeinem
Update sage. Also ich freue mich jeden Monat
die Home Assistant
Updates zu lesen.
In letzter Zeit hat sich ein bisschen viel Kosmetik getan,
aber Kosmetik, das darf man nicht
unterschätzen, ist das was
Noobst zu solchen Produkten bringt.
Oh, er ist schon fertig.
Ja, die Voice Geschichte ging
ein bisschen an mir vorbei, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Ja.
Ok, also.
Wir packen
das wieder, weil ich find, ich find
die Funktion mega praktisch, die ich da gebaut hab.
ESP Error
Any
Erst das da.
Dann das da. Ok,
muss man wirklich hinten dran. Error.
Dann sagen wir sowas wie
Beste Zeit.
Ja, ist ja schon ewig her.
Dann werfen wir ein Warning
an der Stelle, wenn es einen Fehler gegeben hat
und sagen, irgendwie Read Temp
Failed.
Das kann weg.
Das Info unten ist ok.
Das können wir da lassen.
Schreiben wir einfach
wie Temp Read
Grad Celsius.
Ich hoffe das Ding.
Moment, liest das? Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Kekona Alarm.
Liest das überhaupt in
Zelt? Ja, macht das.
Nochmal Glück gehabt, Alter.
Nicht in
Ounces und Fahrenheit und solche komischen
Dinger. Man weiß nie.
Kekona Time.
Wo ist denn mein Kekona Emote,
wenn man das braucht?
Ich hab das Kekomrit Emote.
Hier.
Aber es ist, es ist Celsius.
Zum Glück.
Besser viele
das Grad Celsius in ASCII Code
ausgeben. Was?
Komm mal auf Deutsch, please.
Jetzt haben wir das ausgelesen.
Sekunde. Jetzt müssen wir es
per ZigBee schicken. Das habe ich vergessen,
wie das funktioniert. Das hatten wir das letzte Mal.
Haben wir das schon gemacht.
Aber keine Ahnung mehr. Da muss ich mal nachgucken hier.
Irgendwo. Hier ist es doch noch.
ZigBee Sensor.
Ne.
Ne, das ist was anderes.
Hier.
Wie ging das nochmal mit dem
ZigBee? Irgendwas mit Lock.
Ah ja, hier.
Hier.
Temperature. Lock Acquire.
Endpoint.
Okay, das hier.
Das brauchen wir, um das per ZigBee
zu senden. Also. Measured Value.
Convert. Ja, da habe ich was eigenes
für Convert.
Und außerdem heißt es Temp und nicht Temperature.
Die China-Chinesen können nicht richtig
abkürzen.
Lock Acquire. Und was?
Lock Acquire gibt ein Bool
zurück. Dann sollten wir vielleicht
doch auch.
Mal checken, ob da True
zurückkommt, bevor wir weitermachen.
Sensor Endpoint. Da muss rein.
Sensor ID.
Vermutlich.
Hoffe ich mal.
Measured Value. Das heißt nicht.
Das heißt Converted Temp.
So, und jetzt sollte der eigentlich
kontinuierlich per ZigBee neue
Tastatursachen nach Home Assistant schicken.
Also, noch haben wir
in Home Assistant
minus 327 Grad.
Da habe ich hier alles drin.
Create Task. Sensor.
Delay.
Ich hoffe das crasht jetzt nicht und das
kompiliert und das tut und macht.
Das sollte jetzt gleich in ZigBee
die Temperaturen updaten.
Force Champ. Force Champ.
Das hat doch das letzte Mal schon
funktioniert.
Habe ich irgendwas falsch gemacht?
Was ist hier
Sensor Endpoint?
Sensor Endpoint.
Und 10.
Ja doch, ist doch richtig.
23 ist Funst.
Easy.
Ja.
Es überträgt. Ok.
Leute, ich beweise es euch nochmal.
Ich setz mich nochmal
drauf auf den Sensor.
So, ich sitze.
Ich weiß nicht was für ein Update Intervall.
Ok, jede Sekunde irgendwie.
Ich weiß nicht was für ein Update Intervall
dieses ZigBee Zeug hat.
Ist das Hyperland? Nein. Das ist I3.
Das ist 100 Jahre älter
als Hyperland und läuft dafür auch
gescheit in der VM. Was Hyperland nicht
richtig macht. Mal kurz
Nachtisch mir reinhauen.
Während wir hier dem
Sensor beim Risen zugucken.
Ja, da riset er der
Sensor.
27,8 haben wir schon.
Mein Hintern ist warm heute.
Hypergachi.
Eindeutig funktioniert das mit dem Sensor
in der Temperatur.
Weil, eben hatten wir noch
20 und jetzt haben wir über 30 seitdem ich drauf
hocke.
Ich glaube gar nicht mal, dass Home Assistant langsam ist.
Ich vermute, dass es an meiner
Config hier liegt. Ja, mit dem Intervall
und sowas.
Ich hab nur keine...
Default Minimum Reporting
Intervall. Was bedeutet
eine 1 hier an der Stelle?
Man weiß es nicht. In welcher Einheit
ist das? Minuten? Jede Minute?
Was bedeutet eine 1?
Keine Ahnung.
Interessanter.
Was bedeutet Delta U16 gleich 100?
Ah.
Wie viel sich das changen kann
von einer Nachricht zur nächsten?
Ja gut, dass ich da 100 reingeschrieben habe.
Das wird nie der Fall sein.
Guck mal, 32,9 Grad schon.
Ja, ich würde sagen,
das funktioniert doch wirklich ausgesprochen gut, oder?
Da kann man sich jetzt nicht beschweren.
Also, und,
und dazu kommt,
das ist sogar noch halbwegs lesbar.
Warum ist der Graph bei minus 330 Grad?
Weil mein Sensor
initial mal bei minus 330 Grad war.
Das war der Default-Wert
aus irgendwelchen Gründen. Aber guck,
jetzt,
jetzt geht er,
geht er wieder hoch.
Der hat minus
330 Grad reported.
Senior
Zigbee Developer. Ja.
Gleich LinkedIn Profil updaten.
So ist richtig.
Und dann ist ja auch jeder gefühlte zweite CEO.
So nach dem Motto
CEO von der Mülltonne vor meinem Haus.
Aber Hauptsache CEO.
So funktioniert das doch, ja.
Wie sagen sie immer?
Fake it till you make it.
Das ist nur Zigbee ohne MQTT to Zigbee.
Ja, richtig.
Zigbee to MQTT müssen wir auch noch ausprobieren.
Weil das eigentlich meine bevorzugte
Variante ist, Zigbee Geräte einzubinden.
Also Leute,
ich bin begeistert, wie easy das war.
Seinen eigenen Zigbee Temperatursensor
mit dem
Espressif Zeug zu entwickeln.
Zeilen
und
ey
verhältnismäßig lesbar.
Ok, ein paar Sachen habe ich auch noch
bisschen aufgehübscht.
Oder was
sagt ihr? Kann man sich doch nicht beschweren.
Habe ich schon deutlich Schlimmeres gesehen.
Könnte vielleicht den
Graben noch aus...
ausgliedern.
Oh, Leute, ich habe eine richtig eklige Idee.
Wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen?
Damit ich die Logausgabe
nur an einer Stelle schreiben muss.
Ihr wisst worauf das rausläuft, oder?
Gucken ob das funktioniert.
Kunst.
Ne, hat schon wieder gebuggt.
Hat schon wieder gebuggt.
Ah, weil das Return da drunter steht.
Return muss da drüberstehen.
Siehste, direkt die Probleme von GoTo gleich mal
wieder demonstriert.
Ne, der ist hier rausgelaufen
und dann da unten reingelaufen, wo er überhaupt nicht hin soll.
Deswegen hat er das jetzt mehrfach
ausgegeben.
Siehste, wieder GoTo-Shit
direkt live
Praxisbeispiel
demonstriert.
Warum GoTo eine schlechte Idee ist.
Chat, erlaubt ihr mir
GoTo zu benutzen an der Stelle?
Dass ich nur einmal die Logausgabe schreiben muss?
Ich mein, man könnte das einfach
auch in eine Funktion packen.
Man könnte
auch einfach sagen
Log
sigpi info
oder sowas
und das dann da reinpacken
und
das einmal
hier aufrufen
und einmal hier aufrufen.
Das geht auch.
Ist vielleicht die schönere Variante.
Anstatt dazu GoToon.
So, Funst.
Funst ausgesprochen gut.
Ich bin begeistert.
So, was gibt's denn jetzt noch,
was wir ausprobieren müssen?
Sigpi to MQTT.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Was ganz wichtiges müssen wir noch machen und zwar
Partitionstabelle.
Partitionstabelle
ist die Beispiel-Partitionstabelle.
Die ist aber ziemlicher
Schrott.
Weil die gar nicht meinen kompletten
kompletten
Guck mal, die sind bloß
900k.
Also im Prinzip verschwende ich gerade
3 Megabyte
von meinem
Flashspeicher. Den könnte ich nicht benutzen.
Vielleicht
sollten wir für OTA noch eine zweite
Partition, also so ist die
Partitionstabelle kacke.
Ich hoffe es gibt irgendwelche
Partitiongenerator
oder sowas.
Sowas da vielleicht.
Okay, ich hoffe das taugt was.
Coredump, Overrated, Debugging.
So lange es First Drive
funktioniert, Overrated.
Dann machen
wir doch mal. Machen wir mal eine eigene Partitionstabelle.
Mein Flash ist
4 MB groß, das ist richtig.
Das können wir tatsächlich sogar so lassen.
Zur Lautstärkeregelung der einzelnen Anwendungen.
Also ehrlich, sowas würde ich mir
nicht selbst bauen.
So Partition Table, also
was ist das erste was wir brauchen?
NVS.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es NVS heißen muss.
Data Type
oder was?
Data NVS
Wunderbar.
Das lassen wir mal Default, da weiß ich nämlich nicht.
So das nächste ist
PyInit
ist Data
Py.
Das kriegt
Lassen wir auch mal Default.
Warte mal.
Size, okay.
F00
Size 100
Okay.
Ich habe keine Ahnung was das genau ist.
So und jetzt kommt die Partition
Die Partition für
die
für die eigentliche Firmware.
Die muss glaube ich auf
Factory heißen, sonst buggt das
nicht um.
Offset an 1000 oder an 10.000
So und jetzt
will ich eigentlich meinen
kompletten Flash, kann man das auch in Bytes
schauen, ja. Jetzt will ich eigentlich
meinen kompletten Flash
da reinpacken. Also 300
Alter, what?
What? Leute ich tippe gerade
ich tippe 3
Dafuck, was ist das für ein Editor?
Macht der einen Hex oder was?
Alter, was ist das für ein Schrott?
1, 1, 1, 1,
1, 1, okay.
Hä?
5, 6
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist nicht mehr viel Platz.
Ich habe den Editor immer noch nicht gecheckt.
Aber ein bisschen Platz
ein bisschen Platz müssen wir noch lassen.
Nämlich für
ZB Storage, das muss 16k sein
und ZB fuckt
ZB fuckt
braucht 1 Kilo
also
16k
also lassen wir, machen wir mal so
ok
und jetzt brauchen wir noch
ZB Storage
Datafat
fat
16k
und
jetzt ZB fuckt
muss wahrscheinlich auch Datafat sein
und das kriegt die Verbleibenden
ok
wir haben eine eigene Partitionstabelle gebaut
partitions.csv
von
downloads
partitions
ich speichere mir das mal kurz zwischen
partitions hier hin
partitions
eh
ja
ja, das ist die neue
die flashen
wir jetzt mal
jetzt sollte ich
nämlich einfach meinen kompletten flash
speicher benutzen können für Firmware und nicht
irgendwie nur
ein Drittel
oh er muss neu kompilieren
warum auch immer die Partitionstabelle
das neu kompilieren des gesamten
Projektes braucht
man weiß es nicht
aber das Ding kompiliert gerne mal neu zwischendurch
was macht
eigentlich mein Home Assistant, ist der noch am updaten?
ja
ok 35 Grad ist es unter meinem Popes
unter
wohlgemerkt
also das kommt gut hin denke ich
er flasht, flashchamp
und es funkt
joint fail
ach so, ja
ich dab
mit dem neu partitionieren
ist ja auch
die bestehenden sigbidaten auf dem Gerät gelöscht worden
das heißt ich muss es nochmal neu pairen
ok
das war natürlich jetzt ein bisschen doof
also
schweißen wir den mal weg
remove ok
add device
guck mal
es ist geil wie gut das funktioniert
äh
ich hab nix gesagt
er ist angeblich
gejoint aber das Gerät taucht nicht auf
vielleicht hätte ich das
ja vielleicht hätte ich das Gerät nicht löschen dürfen
jetzt ist er
jetzt ist er hart am rumbanken glaube ich
ok
äh
da gibt es so eins erase flash
benutze sigbi to mqtt
nein benutze ich nicht
das probieren wir jetzt aber aus
mit sigbi to mqtt gleich
ich hab
ok ist er fertig flashen
äh while
ja ist nix mehr drauf und jetzt
flashchamp
nochmal neu die Firma drauf klatschen
jetzt sollte es eigentlich
jetzt sollte es eigentlich wieder gehen
joining sigbi network
hä ach ja
piss dich also
ey die logik die logik muss ich
nicht verstehen aber es scheint zu funktionieren
35,4 grad haben wir
er hat es gecheckt
mein Gerät ist wieder da
wisst ihr was ich super weird finde
wie man das hier schreiben muss
sensor vendor sensor name
davor muss
aus irgendwelchen gründen
äh
9 als byte stehen
da gibt es
hier auch eine eine erklärung
für warum das so sein muss
und zwar
manufacturer
the string should be started with the
length of its own also sprich
das hier
die länge in byte
als prefix
wisst ihr ich fand ja
ich war ja noch nie ein großer fan von 0 terminierten
strings aber
irgendwie hat sich die halbe welt auf 0 terminiertes
strings geeinigt oder was ist die halbe welt
99% der welt
haben sich auf 0 terminiertes strings geeignet
warum muss es denn jetzt
prefixed werden mit der länge
das ist sehr unintuitiv
stimmt das denn überhaupt
expressive hat
1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8
9 und es ist 0
b
b ist 11 in hex
die wissen auch nicht was sie machen oder
1 2 3
4 5 6 7
8 9
selbst wenn ich das hier mitzähle
komme ich nicht
auf 11
das ergibt keinen sinn
ich mein meins stimmt
1 2 3 4 5
6 7
warum habe ich da 09 hingeschrieben
wenn es hä
achso
weil es davor nochmal 2 byte braucht
die anführungszeichen zählen sicherlich nicht mit
aber
die länge
zählt selbst damit
alter das ist ja so
ultra weird man
dann sind es nochmal 11
wenn das mit reinkommt
es sind immer 2 mehr
hä
wer hat sich denn das ausgedacht man
kann man die dinger nicht einfach 0 terminaten
und gut ist
wobei
chatgear mal an die c kenner eine frage
wenn ich das so schreibe
dann ist das automatisch ein 0 terminierter string oder
also hier ist
hintendran tatsächlich noch ein versteckter
versteckter 0 oder
deswegen ist es auch 9
es ist einmal hier das spezielle zeichen
dann
7 davon und nochmal die 0
was ja auch heißen würde
chatgear mal kurz mal kurz
um meine theorie
zu überprüfen
das hier
müsste jetzt länge 1 sein weil 0 terminiert ist
ja korrekt
leere string ist
länge 1 weil 0 terminiert
dann stimmt 9
was ich da eingetragen habe das ist richtig
weil
es ist 0 es sind
zeichen plus
ist halt die frage ob das hier mitgezählt wird
was meint ihr
wird das mitgezählt oder wird das nicht mitgezählt selbst
ich mein
laut ey das ist super super weird
sigpi
manufacturer
prefix bytes
string ich google mal irgendwas
ok
bei tuja kommen wir da raus
manufacturer name
the value of the attribute
is 16 bytes
in length ok
das ist tuja
spezialitäten
ok keine ahnung was
da abgeht wir lassen es einfach
mal so und
wir hoffen dass es so geht
so jetzt checke ich
das ganze nochmal schnell mit sigpi
to mqtt wie das hier funktioniert
dazu sollten
wir die
home assistant sigpi integration
ja wir sollten
mal mqtt configern gut
die home assistant configuration
hauen wir mal raus
wie kann ich denn das jetzt wieder entfernen
sigpi
delete
ich glaube ich muss das vorher
kann ich das nicht noch überschreiben lassen
ich muss einmal
die settings nochmal überschreiben lassen
dass sich das ding
nicht wieder anmeldet
delete ok ich formatier
das ding nochmal den stick
home assistant
mqtt sigpi
addon das muss man erstmal hinzufügen
genau
can be installed hier
das braucht man alles klar
ich bevorzuge sigpi
to mqtt versus
die standard home assistant
sigpi geschichte
weil die mehr geräte
unterstützen und ich damit
weniger probleme erwarte
ich habe die sigpi home assistant integration nie
ausgiebig getestet weil ich
schon ganz lange auf sigpi to mqtt bin
keinen grund sehe das
umzusteigen
auf home assistant lets go
wir können schon mal
das addon installieren
übrigens es gibt
einen coolen shortcut in home assistant drückt ihr
einfach c wenn ihr im web interface seid
dann habt ihr so ein command
panel
bisschen wie in visual studio code
und da kommt man deutlich schneller mit hin
anstatt
rum geklicke navigiere
so sigpi
genau und e um geräte
und sowas zu suchen
hier sigpi to mqtt
wollen wir installieren install
ok finish
ja wunderbar
das ist
alter
ich hab gesagt du sollst neu anfangen
und du sollst dir nicht das gerät
merken man
kack noob
ok ich löscht es jetzt
delete
so und jetzt machen wir
das ganze mit sigpi
sigpi to mqtt
wir müssen das gerät einmal resetten
damit es sich versucht neu anzumelden
no network found
ja wunderbar
der sollte jetzt eigentlich immer weiter machen
macht der nicht
no network found
ach ne da macht der nicht weiter
ja da muss ich den wohl nochmal resetten
erase flash
bam
ok
configuration
wie config
sigpi
to mqtt addon home assistant
ja
ok
explaining
hex filen
okay
ok
flash okay so jetzt starten wir mal dass er doch ich hoffe das funktioniert mit
dem stick da ich nicht rebuten muss der herzmann sp 32 flächen aus bsl gz mit
rust ich sehe schon krusten tier enjoyer am
start weg vielleicht einfach ins ab habe ich
glaube übersehen set set mqtt habe ich schon am start okay was auch immer
web ui okay er hat noch nix er hat noch nix gefunden join failed join failed
alles klar dann permit join hoffentlich zeugt er jetzt auch aha
joint
gut das ding hat probleme mit meinen komischen guck mal hier das mag er nicht
seht ihr es er ist pc 6 das mag er nicht mit diesen komischen der denkt der
string ist länger als er eigentlich also zählt es doch nicht mit leute dann zählt
das doch nicht mit dann hat es presse da in ihrem tutorial
mist stehen dann ist das hier acht weil das brief ich selber nicht mit zählt
gut das ding hat probleme mit meinen komischen guck mal hier das mag er nicht
okay wie kriege ich in den jetzt kann man die dinge irgendwie neu scannen
lassen wenn man die schon mal hinzugefügt hat
reconfigure okay successful ja das hat aber im namen nichts geändert
die ok scheiß mal auf den namen die frage ist jetzt viel eher ob das bei
den wobei wir können einfach geräte suchen esp ja funktioniert
wir kommen auf 올해 Guardo
week 2
dvd w jetzt
wir haben jetzt über wir haben das gerät jetzt über 60 i
devo mqtt drin er nur das dumme ist dass das ding so kacke heißt hiermit also ich glaube das ist einfach einmal zu viel sage lange für den suck weil ich nicht schon gesagt habe weil ich das gerät jetzt flasche aber komplett leer mache und entferne aus als tippettons
aus Wells Eye ComicsENVOTER.ly
Aus SIGPY 2M QTT.
Ich muss das mal hier anpinnen.
Wenn ich das hier raus entferne.
Und danach nochmal neu aufnehme.
Checkt der dann.
Dass das Gerät.
Hallo.
Pale to remove device.
Ja das macht ja schon mal Bock.
Force removing.
Wie force remove ich denn?
So.
Ah hier.
Force remove.
Bam.
Du wurdest force removed.
Piss dich also.
Weg damit.
So der flasht immer noch.
Auf factory settings.
Ja das ist die Frage.
Muss man 0 nicht mit angeben?
Oder das Prefix?
Wir werden es jetzt sehen.
Ich habe jetzt ja.
Ich habe 8 drin anstatt 9.
Sollte das jetzt.
Sollte das weggehen.
Alter ist ja heute nochmal fertig mit flashen.
Was flasht denn der da so lang?
Auch 4 MB sind schnell geflasht.
Aha fertig.
Okay.
Invalidität.
Hedda.
Das ist nicht USB 2.
Ah das Ding ist sogar USB 3.
Aber mal davon abgesehen.
Das hat nur.
Also das ist ja immer noch seriell.
So.
Permit join.
Sollte der sich wieder anmelden?
Joined.
Alter.
Ich glaube der hat es nicht gelöscht.
Der hat es nicht gelöscht richtig.
Ich könnte wetten.
Wenn das jetzt zum ersten Mal joinen würde.
Wäre das ja alles gut.
Wie kriege ich meinen ZigBee Stick komplett resettet?
Moment.
Flash.
Wir flashen das nochmal.
Nein nein nein.
Flash.
Nochmal das.
Das.
Erase vielleicht.
Ich habe einen Sonoff ZigBee Stick Reset.
Wie resettet man den komplett?
To Reset.
Was Wireless Switch?
Stick.
Reset.
Ja wie geht das?
Oh vielleicht soll ich das doch nicht machen.
Ähm.
Ich bin mir unsinnig.
Ich bin mir unsicher ob das so eine gute Idee ist das zu löschen.
Aber wisst ihr was wir machen können?
Wir Jibaden das Teil einfach.
Wir machen das Addon aus.
Ich weiß was wir machen.
Mein Home Assistant kann es ja anscheinend.
So.
Wir stoppen das Addon.
Wir gehen in die Home Assistant.
Integration.
Fügen dort den ZigBee Stick hinzu.
Und sagen neues Netzwerk.
Dann löscht er das.
Dann schmeißen wir es in Home Assistant wieder raus.
Und dann nehmen wir das Addon.
Dann sollte es.
Ich meine.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt was besseres.
Aber.
Reset.
Äh.
Das ist super advancer Shit anscheinend.
Erase Network Settings and create a new Network.
Genau.
Wenn es nicht so lahm wäre in Home Assistant.
Dann würde ich das deutlich mehr feiern.
Die ZigBee Integration.
So.
ZigBee GMQTT ist aus.
Mein Gerät ist auch aus.
Der meckert jetzt das er keine Firmware drauf hat.
Was auch gut so ist.
Du Du Du Du.
Home Assistant.
Ach hinne.
Du Du Du Du.
Du hast den ESP32 überhaupt nicht.
Lüg nicht rum.
Der ist ja gerade ohne Firmware.
Und sendet überhaupt nichts.
So.
Der Herzmann ist slow.
Herzmann?
Aha, was?
What?
Wo kommt denn dieses fucking Device her, Mann?
Das ist weg.
Ich hab das Ding eben gelöscht.
Das Gerät hat nicht mal eine Firmware drauf, Alter.
The fuck?
Okay, ich hab ne Idee, woran das liegt.
Ich glaube...
Okay.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich glaube, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Das versucht mitzudenken, Leute.
Das ist eine ganz schlechte Idee, wenn das versucht mitzudenken.
Wir brauchen das Add-on für SSH.
Terminal.
Weil da garantiert noch übrig gebliebene Sachen von dem letzten Add-on,
irgendwelche Caches übrig geblieben sind.
Alter, ist das ein Akt, so einen ZigBee-Stick zu resetten?
Ich werd verrückt.
Connected Mode, nix hier.
Configuration.
Passwort.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Highly secure.
Secure.
130.
Start.
Okay.
SSH.
Has IO at 130.
Gigant minus R 130.
Okay.
Yes.
So, und ich wette mit euch unter Home Assistant...
ZigBee to...
Ja, guck mal, da liegt noch der ganze Shit vom letzten Mal.
EM minus EF, Sternchen.
Bam.
Yep.
Okay.
So, ich hoffe, jetzt geht's besser.
Oder ich hab's Add-on kaputt gemacht, muss das Add-on neu installieren.
So, schauen wir mal.
Okay, da liegt wieder Zeug.
Das ist gut.
Der hat's neu initialisiert.
Initialized.
Ich mein, das Gerät kann offensichtlicherweise gerade nicht gehen.
Das hat keine Firmware drauf.
Okay, nice.
Und jetzt OpenWebUI.
Wenn das jetzt immer noch da ist, dreh ich durch.
Nein, ist nicht wieder da.
Okay.
Flash.
Join.
Wenn es jetzt falsch heißt, hab ich keinen Bock mehr.
Dann kann...
Dann lebe ich halt mit dem...
Mit dem Fragezeichen und dem nicht richtigen...
Namen dran.
Join ZigBee.
Ah, jetzt heißt es richtig.
Okay.
Jetzt heißt es richtig, alles klar.
Okay, nice.
Heißt im Endeffekt...
Es hat alles richtig gut funktioniert.
Hier ist das Device.
Das dem geben wir jetzt vielleicht noch einen halbwegs sinnvollen Namen.
Die weiß es.
Was?
Model ist Auto Generated.
Echt?
Warum?
Das Model steht doch da drinne.
Ist überhaupt nicht Auto Generated das Model.
Laber nicht.
Ist genauso wie es drinne steht.
Okay, umbenennen würdest du in ZigBee zu MQTT.
Ja, die Frage ist nur...
Wie?
Friendly Name.
Das würde ich gerne umbenennen, ja.
Ach hier.
Ja, dann nennen wir das jetzt mal...
Äh, ja.
Fischteich.
Hä, hallo?
Äh...
Ich kann das nicht ändern.
Muss man das noch irgendwie einschalten?
Wie ändert man das?
Edit?
Aha.
Update Home Assistant Entity ID.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Sinniger.
Fischteich.
Ist ja eh nur zum Testen.
ESP.
Könnte es auch so sein.
Fischteich Temp.
Okay.
Wow.
Way to dank.
Hat umbenannt.
Temperature is unknown.
Ist irgendwie broken.
Obwohl der eigentlich die Temperatur updaten sollte hier.
Ich glaube, ich glaube wir haben es irgendwie ein bisschen kaputt gemacht mit dem umbenennen, weil hier das checkt das, dass es 35,6 Grad ist.
Ach, jetzt hat das okay.
Ja, 35,68 Grad.
Link Quality.
Ach, das kapiert er jetzt auch.
Was ist MQTT Select?
Hängt das denn an einem Akku?
Wenn ja, wäre die Spannung nicht interessant.
Aktuell nicht.
In Zukunft schon.
Und ja, genau.
Da hast du recht.
Ja.
Das steht auch noch auf dem Plan, dass wir das mal batterietauglich fit machen.
Ich habe ein Board, was im Deep Sleep fast nix braucht, nur ähm 16 Mikroampere.
Das heißt, wenn das vier Stunden Deep Sleept, dann misst's verschickt und wenn der Deep Sleept, hält das zwei Jahre an.
Bei 1.200, äh, Milliampere Stunden an einem 200, äh, 1.200 Milliampere Stunden Akku.
Und das ist schon recht großzügig gerechnet, aber praktisch wird's wahrscheinlich trotzdem ein bisschen weniger sein.
Wobei, doch, kommt hin, das ist ja in Wirklichkeit sogar so ein 2.000 Milliampere Stunden Akku, habe ich gerade gesehen.
Wusste ich auch nicht, dass der so groß ist.
Ja, nice.
Übrigens, Leute, wem so Streams gefallen, bisschen Sellout muss sein, ja, ich freue mich selbstverständlich, äh, nicht nur über Subs, sondern auch über Follows.
Das heißt, wer in Zukunft wieder mit am Start sein will, kann mir gerne jetzt followen.
Sellout beendet.
Ich mag eh viel zu wenig Sellout, gell.
Das Subscriben ist natürlich auch super, dankeschön, Laki.
Alter, mein Poppest ist richtig hot, 36 Grad.
So.
Ich setz mich mal wieder runter vom Sensor.
Guck, schon wird's kühler.
Schon wird's kühler.
Kaum hab ich mich runtergesetzt vom Sensor.
Sehr nice.
Ja.
Ich hab drauf gesessen.
Also das war die Temperatur von meinem Hintern hier.
Knapp 36 Grad.
Also ich hab kein Fieber oder so, wie's aussieht.
Bits, ja, dankeschön.
Zehn Milliarden Bits.
Leute, gestern war ich drei Stunden Fahrrad fahren.
Ich merk's heut immer.
Und heut Morgen noch, äh, heut Morgen noch mal eine halbe Stunde so entspannungsmäßig eine Runde rennen.
Das ist echt...
Ich merk's immer noch richtig hart in den Beinen von gestern.
Drei Stunden ist echt...
Auf mehr hätt ich echt keinen Bock.
So.
Ja, Temperatur geht runter.
Er hat keine Statistik.
Wir haben's mit dem Umbenennen, glaub ich, kaputt gemacht.
Ach, das checkt er, okay.
Also die Graphen in Home Assistant sind grausam, ey.
Ich mag das überhaupt nicht.
Das ist super hakelig.
Auch hier die Zeitauswahl und sowas.
Jo.
Ich glaube, das war's für heute, oder?
Ach nee, was ich nochmal gucken wollte.
Hier, ESP32.
Fire Beetle.
Die Voltage.
Ich nenn's mal trotzdem Battery.
Ob man das...
Ob die da irgendeinen Pin haben oder so, wo man das abfragen kann.
Das ist das alte Board.
Mit dem normalen ESP32.
Der Output Voltage auf den Pin.
Wie ist das hier?
Power Source.
Man kann das bestimmt auslesen.
Read.
Voltage.
VIN.
Oder muss ich da ein Kabel legen?
Battery.
Okay.
Na, die machen das selbst, ja.
Ja, die packen tatsächlich den offenen GPIO.
Und machen dann Analog-Digital-Konverter.
Und gucken, wie viel Spannung anlegt.
Es gibt anscheinend echt nichts eingebautes.
Moment.
Es ist angeblich schon was connected.
Ja, ist klar.
Da kämpf ich mich jetzt ganz bestimmt durch.
Ja.
ESP32, C6.
Gmatics.
Weil ich ja genau der Richtige für Energydrinks bin, ne?
Vielleicht hat das auch schon irgendeinen GPIO-Pin, wo das standardmäßig drauf ist.
Wo man das auslesen kann.
Hier lest ihr...
Hier kommt die Batterie.
Vielleicht hat das schon was.
Das habe ich übrigens vorhin gesucht und nicht gefunden.
Ist das irgendwo schon angeschlossen?
Ich sehe da jetzt nichts zu...
Ja, guckt hier drüber.
Könnte man beispielsweise an Solarpanels anschließen.
Die automatisch die Batterie auslösen.
Weil das Ding Ladeelektronik hat.
Das ist für Displays.
Brauche ich nicht.
Wobei es eigentlich richtig, richtig nice ist, da drüber Displays anzuschließen.
Viel angenehmer als diesen ganzen Krempel über GPIOs anzustöpseln.
Ja, das gucke ich mir jetzt bestimmt nicht an.
Also GPIO36 ist connected zu...
Das ist bei dem anderen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das bei dem auch so ist.
Aber vielleicht.
Ja.
Battery.
Wollte ich nicht.
Ja.
Voltage.
IONull.
Wo hast du das gelesen?
Wenn man kaum ist, muss man mal ordentlich lesen.
IONull.
Meinen die damit...
Was ja schon mal Sinn macht, weil das nicht nach draußen geführt ist.
Okay.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Testen wir einfach mal, oder?
Testen wir mal.
Im Prinzip brauchen wir dann nichts hiervon.
Nichts davon.
Machen wir einfach jetzt hier.
Analog.
Ich...
Boah.
Ich habe lange nichts mehr gelesen mit Arduino.
Ähm...
Ich weiß nicht, ob man da im Vorfeld irgendwas machen muss.
Da musste man doch irgendwie Pin-Mode oder sowas noch einstellen.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich bilde mir ein.
Man musste...
Was ist IONull?
Pin-Mode.
Ja, Pin-Mode.
GPIO...
Null.
Pin-Mode.
Oh nee, wie ging das denn jetzt nochmal?
Mode?
Ist schon zu lang her.
Output, input. Okay.
Input.
Und jetzt Analog Read
GPIO Null.
Schauen wir mal.
LOG.
LOGGER. INFO.
Ey, was kommt denn da zurück?
Ein...
U16. Okay.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wenn das funktioniert.
Out of the box wäre
extremely pog.
Also was auch immer das ist,
das ergibt jetzt wenig Sinn.
Was ich interessant finde,
ist, dass es schon
relativ konstant der gleiche Wert ist.
Also der möchte mir
schon irgendwas sagen.
Ich meine, aktuell bin ich ja auch über USB dran.
Aktuell bin ich über USB
dran. Deswegen hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht,
dass glatt
3,3 Volt rauskommt.
An der Stelle, weil das ja umgewandelt
wird von USB.
Jetzt müsste man jetzt echt mal mit einer Batterie testen.
Unsigned ins...
Ja.
Ich kann den Pin nirgends wo hinschließen.
Der Pin wird nicht rausgeführt.
Den man... Das kann schon
sein, dass man sich den auch umrechnen muss.
Jaja, das ist schon richtig.
Das ist
schon richtig.
Genau. Das ist...
Du hast recht. Das ist der
Analog-Digital-Konverter-Wert.
Ich habe aber
keine Ahnung, was da rauskommen kann.
Gibt es hier irgendwas?
Da muss man bestimmt noch was einstellen.
ADC, Arduino.
Da kann man bestimmt noch irgendwie
Precision oder sowas.
Ja, genau.
Dieses Eingangspins mit Standard-Auflösen.
P32.
ADC, Battery.
Ja.
Das ist die Frage.
Also, ich würde sagen,
dass dieser Wert,
dass mit Volt dahinter kann man verändern,
dass dieser Wert jetzt halt ziemlich genau 3,3 Volt entspricht.
Aber die Frage ist,
wie der Verlauf ist.
Okay, was ist, wenn man auf
Resolution 12 wechselt?
Das ist jetzt einfach nur geraten, ja.
Kommt im Prinzip
genau das gleiche raus.
Ja, da weiß ich jetzt nicht, wie man das
umrechnet.
Keine Ahnung.
Das muss man jetzt.
Okay.
Pfeifert, okay, Pfeifert.
Okay, what?
Okay.
Also, was, was soll ich machen?
Analog Reading mal Referenz Voltage.
Wo soll ich das wissen?
Was ist denn meine Referenz Voltage?
Alter, wie ich keinen Plan habe.
Aha.
Basic Tutorial.
Da gibt es sogar einen Guide zu.
Ich kack nur.
Voltage Calculation.
Wie wäre es einfach mal in den Guide zu gucken?
Hier.
Bam.
Die machen hier nichts, ne.
Die sagen Analog Resolution 12.
Okay.
Ja, das mache ich jetzt auch.
Alle Rien GPIO 0.
Öh.
Da gibt einfach gar nichts aus.
Ach, Serial Printline.
Ja, das funzt ja nicht bei mir gescheit.
Das muss ich,
das muss ich ändern in Logger Loginfo.
Das Serial Printline ist bisschen broken.
Ja, das ist, bin ich mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Also, ich vermute 3,3.
Äh, die Ausgabe funzt nicht.
Ah, ist das ein Float?
Was da rauskommt?
Das ist schlecht.
Ich habe Float Support für die, für das Formatting ausgeschaltet.
Oh, nee.
Okay.
Ich, ich wollte nicht.
Ich, ich dachte, ich muss keine Floats formatieren.
Ich dachte, ich kann ein bisschen Flash-Speicher sparen.
Okay, Print, Print, dann Print F'en wir das jetzt.
Okay, Print, Print F.
Was ist denn bei, was ist denn ein Float?
F, A.
Okay, wir haben 5,4.
Das liegt daran, weil es per USB angeschlossen ist.
Macht ja auch Sinn.
Aber intern läuft er trotzdem mit 3,3.
Wie kommt der hier auf diese Magic, Magic Nummer?
Sollten es nicht 5 sein?
Das ist die Rev-Voltage.
Aber woher weiß man das?
Man, man muss es halt einfach wissen.
Aber nice, dass das funktioniert mit dem, mit dem Batterieladung.
Da können wir das nächste Mal weitermachen an der Stelle.
Das nächste Mal bauen wir das ein bisschen um.
Auf Deep Sleep und Batteriebetrieb.
Akriege, Chat.
Nice.
Excellent.
Ziehen wir das mal raus und heben den Controller auf.
Dass ich nicht drüberfalle.
Alles klar, Chat.
Schön, dass so viele dabei waren.
Über drei Stunden Bastelstelz.
Wird mal wieder Zeit.
Macht's gut.
Tschüss.
Handlieg.
Nochmal zum Schluss.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Bis dann.
See you.